and we're live joy ideas my brother I
feeling like a new [ __ ] man rested
you I know rested right rested very
rested I looked at it at this as a reset
button as soon as I came back from Vegas
I know what time it was February 29th it
was a 50% opacity yeah we were there a
week later we were there when Tommy was
at the Mirage in the UFC had their there
Vegas the Las Vegas card it was it was a
ghost town just half not even half full
I mean a week after you you were at 50%
capacity was probably dropping less than
that dirty it was at 30 but do UFC was
packed it was packed yeah and then I
came to the Comedy Store March 2nd and
that's when I could smell it in the
[ __ ] air when I went into the green
room bro and I saw all those people in
the green room I basically had a [ __ ]
panic attack yeah and I went right to
the door there's a street door yeah in
the back of the Eddie Murphy door if he
comes back that's what this house is
gonna get it out of that guards so I
went to the Eddie Murphy door and I
stayed there and you could just see
people in the audience like nothing was
going on and I just got I just got [ __ ]
like I was shattered by Saturday and
remember I was supposed to be in New
York for Saint Patty's Day and the
Monday before I was supposed to be in
New York the 16th and 17th with a show
at NIACC on the 12th and I saw it
happening I can't went to a doctor's for
a shot off my knee to get the gel for
the arthritis and he said them you might
have a weird reaction to it and sure
enough Tuesday I went to boxing class
and the guy goes dog your leg is bruised
so I had a little bruising on my leg and
I got home and that night on the news
that hit New Rochelle and like a win
second the Rochelle in Nyack they're
like [ __ ] neighbors you know my
memory man I served me right but in my
mind that talked close yeah well pretty
on top of everything so I sent a letter
to picture that might need it it
produces and I said I'm not coming
does they wanted me to come in Thursday
for wardrobe and then I was just gonna
sit in my hotel room for two days you
know I'm go to Jersey and eat [ __ ] like
that so even during all this they were
still planning on filming and this is
for The Sopranos movie so we were gonna
do a couple shoots some reshoots not
reshoot you like extra scenes right that
Tuesday when I got all new Rochelle a
bus I sent them a picture of my knee and
so I'm not getting on a plane till
Friday
I want the swelling to go down but it
doesn't take the [ __ ] I got a GED and
when I was in New York City in May I
went by the garden teeth lunch I wanted
to get out of my hotel room and I went
to the garden on the side you could sit
there at 12 o'clock and they have
everything steak sandwiches whatever you
want pretty [ __ ] good two trucks I
know they have a building that has
floats inside and have some trucked and
you could still outside [ __ ]
beautiful but while I was sitting there
was a Tuesday I was off from shooting
and I remember calling my wife there
specifically saying I like it here
everything but where all these people
can't call yeah if you sit in New York
City in Manhattan like on the 50s and
just sit there at a cafe you could
estimate I mean it's like maybe 10,000
for every 10 minutes that you sit there
people that walk by you we don't have
that foot traffic and now I awake phase
in New York there's a little bit of foot
traffic downtown but Sunset Strip that
ship sailed you don't see people walking
around the Sunset Strip Hollywood
Boulevard but not to the dense popular
you know no not in the numbers of New
York so we said no [ __ ] brain there's
a GED here this is Smith sitting there
gone this is gonna happen I just kept
cutting it down and my biggest fear was
going to the East Coast and getting
stuck it could happen
I would've had to buy a truck the
Cadillac and drove back I was already
prepared like I was like I'm gonna buy a
truck and drive back do you think you do
that drive that's a long ass [ __ ] I
could do it I've done that drugs only
times what is it five days five days
four days
there's what four days you got to do
like what sixteen hours a day
yeah it's hard to stay awake I did
Colorado New Jersey like the back of my
hand how far that early eighties three
what is it from here to Colorado like
here to Denver
I think 16:16 here to Utah Salt Lake is
10/10 that's a good one that's a good
escape that's a good escape I don't have
not but I've done Vegas multiple times
right Vegas is about four and a half
warnet yeah and then you go another six
ish somewhere in that range you get to
Salt Lake depending on traffic it's
awful it's not like you go to Salt Lake
City at 5:00 in the afternoon like all
[ __ ] rush hour
hey where's the cars fly by we thought I
thought Solly said he was like millions
I thought it was like millions of people
it's some Millions
what did we figure it out Jamie didn't
mean it's like a couple hundred thousand
yeah cool [ __ ] place I love it I love
Salt Lake City so with the radius at the
moment the morals mistake on it nobody
knows dick about thick like a reefer
bong grenades great Mexican for a food
you go to that one this is one famous
Mexican joint I some lizard I was
walking around and some guy goes Joey
Diaz I got the perfect spot for you you
seem cool you drop with your Mexican
joint
what is that there's a one famous
Mexican spot in how did you get the
number
it says estimated as 200k but yeah
that's like that goes all the way out to
the mountains
1.2 million that's nothing yeah that's
nothing
no 200,000 in the city and you see those
popping when people would like dense and
then I started hearing that we're gonna
dance or coach our I'm gonna cancel our
childhood that too [ __ ] greedy cancer
coach our dog old people that's what
some Palm Springs
well once they cancel South by Southwest
I was like whoa whoa this is crazy and
the storm was planning on keeping the oh
are open and they cancelled my show in
the main room they asked offered me a
spot in the Ori was like I don't think
we should be doing shows like this just
doesn't seem like this seems like it's
getting real because if you make a
mistake and there's a forty
a period where all these people can get
infected who the [ __ ] knows who gets
infected during those 14 days it's so
because we didn't know what it was yet
and still we don't know what it's still
strange because so many people idris
elba apparently is asymptomatic he's not
showing any symptoms and he has asthma
and I was reading something find out if
this is true that somewhere in the
neighborhood of 60 percent of the people
are asymptomatic and I wonder if that
means they never show symptoms or a
wonder if that means they they're
asymptomatic for a certain period of
time so 60% of people infected are
asymptomatic but a certain percentage of
those people will ultimately get the
cold or get the get the coffin all the
terrible symptoms the fever because you
really ask listen you know a lot of
people I know a lot of people that has
it I have Michael yo Michael yo was
almost dead Michael yo went to New York
City did Gotham he came back he got real
sick you know yes yes he got pneumonia
and the cove in 19 at the same time so
he got coronavirus and pneumonia and he
said now now six days ago I talked to
him two days ago he said for four days
before that he thought he was gonna die
his art couldn't breathe pneumonia and
this korone of I think I think this
[ __ ] winning it like plays with
you if you don't have it if you don't
get it you you can kind of like oh this
is no big deal
but if you do get it it [ __ ] grabs
you like Jamie knows a girl who's 21 who
lost her sense of smell and taste and it
just it wrecks people we were we were
googling a story about this Olympic
swimmer from South Africa 31 stud
athlete Olympic swimmer he said this
virus [ __ ] him up he said it was the
worst thing he's ever experienced so
it's weird it's like it pull it almost
like plays with our mind like it makes
some people seem like they're immune and
some people are fine maybe it's you take
a chance go outside take a chance go to
a restaurant take a chance
to the beach let's go to the page what's
the worst thing that can happen crack
close [ __ ]
and then don't deep [ __ ] it and then
boom a bunch of people in your family
get it and then boom your grandma dies
look at Italy you know what happened
anyway lately
they just went out they all live
together yep yep yep yep they all live
together and they hang together nothing
wrong with that that's how people are I
came from this husband there's a
basement you grandmother and grandfather
living a basement your parents live on
the second floor you live on the third
floor boom we hang out together the
foots go family god bless him from
freehold New Jersey and lost more people
from a family reunion and went to like
that oh yeah sorry yeah I saw that one I
saw the one that the guy had the 39th
Bert the 40th birthday party and the old
guy on planes afterward and went off to
different parts of the country a family
majority was not very old either no the
youngest one that died I think was 55 I
think it's somewhere in that range it's
um
I might do it well I have the mask on am
i jumping up and down at rowlf's buying
groceries no am I going I stop you know
I went to one boxing class after that
yeah was announcing I was like you know
what this is too personal
we haven't give it a chance I got a bag
at the house I got kettle bags at the
house everything could be done out of my
house yeah if you're a person and you
want to work out there's so many YouTube
videos or just bodyweight workouts you
can get a [ __ ] amazing workout with
nothing you don't need any equipment you
just do burpees and push-ups and
bodyweight squats and lunges there's
plenty of working out to do folks and
it's free it's a beautiful thing about
YouTube there's so many really good
fitness instructors to just put their
stuff out there for free because they
want people to follow them and you know
you can get a ton of great bodyweight
workouts you don't need nothing and if
you need weights folks you can pick [ __ ]
up around your house and you could do a
great workout with I'm sure you got a
can of paint somewhere the probably
weighs 15 pounds you know people have
things laying around don't you know how
to start going what because it was [ __ ]
me meditate so what I do is I hit the
bag I broke my work pot because now you
can't do that long workout now because
we're gonna do for the other day for the
restoration day there
read that crime so there's no recovery
my world just some be worried about
every 15 minutes
yeah nice in the back hitting the bag is
very essential yes in the bag is very
essential get the Yaya's out you're
punching you look at anything benefits
over 44 boxing benefits over 50 the
number one benefit is stress you know
for a couple days there Doug I was
getting scared you know I wasn't I'm not
scared of it
but I respect it there's a big
difference I respect what's go on
something's going on I'm not a [ __ ]
scientist have you ever been here in an
earthquake yes this for me it's the same
feeling but but more magnified it's like
okay this is alright but what is it like
if it gets worse right oh yeah where
were you in July I was on [ __ ] stage
we were we were home I didn't even feel
it I didn't even feel it
I was in Beach and the room showed and I
just kept going I just kept going [ __ ]
if a beam falls and hits me this is it
but you don't know why you're on stage I
couldn't let them get scared oh I
couldn't not let them get scared cuz now
you lose the audience right fifty people
in there I know so I could not let 22
minutes brilliant it was perfect I was
just thinking about the other that was
one of my best times I had the last year
would stand up right in the middle I'm
on stage and I had to calm them down so
I just learned to a rant so they didn't
get scared yeah yeah my last show I did
was like a Tuesday or a Wednesday at The
Improv I forget maybe Wednesday did one
show a p.m. show great fun time but I
was like I think this is it this is the
last show for a long time I didn't want
somebody to say they went to the improv
right I didn't want somebody to say that
they got sarikamis yeah
you will never shake that thing is
you'll never know there's no way anybody
could dial it in to one person or you
got it from that's this the weird thing
is we're constantly interacting with
people and touching surfaces and
according to this these cruise liners
that they're testing where these people
were sick even people that are
asymptomatic it shows the virus stays on
surfaces for
much as 17 days that's a new discovery
they thought it was three days before
that now they're realizing even in
asymptomatic people people that don't
spray these it's weird it's a [ __ ]
weird virus man it's real weird real
weird my friend dr. Peter tea I was
saying that most people 55 and under
they seem to just get cold I mean it's a
date they're fine they feel like [ __ ]
for a while but they get over it he said
but then there's this 28 year old
fitness instructor that one of his
friends is treating was a doctor and
he's guys on a ventilator he's a fitness
instructor and they're like there could
be genetic conditions predispositions
and then they're also it might be vaping
they think in that vaping might have
something to do with damaging some
people's lungs you know or cigarette
smoking cigarette smoking is a bad one
and they think that that might have
contributed to a lot of deaths in Italy
and in China out smoke us and they have
less cancer in China see the thing is
are we sure they have less cancer like
when they say they have deaths like how
many deaths they have out of China would
you believe those numbers I don't trust
a [ __ ] word of it they're trying to
say that this is an American disease
that's what the Chinese people are
there's some propaganda Network from
China that's I don't know it's connected
to the government or water may because
people just [ __ ] around
maybe it's people trying to be funny but
they're putting out that this is a
man-made disease that was spread in
China by the United States government so
who the [ __ ] are you trusting I'm not
trusting I trust Italy when it comes to
the numbers because I think they're
being pretty honest about what a
disaster it is but China's trying to
make it seem like everything's bouncing
back now I don't buy it
they opened up the movie theaters in
China yeah movies like one night movie
oh my god watch a horror movie boy
you're in this [ __ ] theater just
wondering if everything you touch is
eventually gonna kill you [ __ ]
apparently they were saying also that it
has something to do with blood type they
don't know
why but a lot of the fatalities were
blood type a seem to be vulnerable or
maybe it's just a coincidence they say
they don't have enough data yet you know
especially here like reliable data that
we can trust here in America they don't
have enough yet so when I when I think
about it what gets me is that same
feeling like an earthquake like once an
earthquake it's like oh alright what
we're okay right now but now we know
that this can happen like the first one
I ever experienced I was the first year
here I had an apartment in North
Hollywood and wasn't it was a thin place
like you could hear the next-door
neighbor she would get phone calls I
would hear her answer machine go off
this is the 90s and I would hear the
person talking on her answering machine
I could hear every conversation she
heard she had like it was through a
towel
like that's how thin it was it was a
shitty apartment but when the earthquake
hit the apartment just went like this
and I remember thinking this is like
when you're a kid and you're playing in
a refrigerator box
remember those refrigerator boxes we
would get him on the street and we all
climb in them and [ __ ] around but they
were they were flimsy I'm like this
house felt like a refrigerator box he
just started moving like this and it
wasn't even a big earthquake it was like
a five something like a five five or
something like that it wasn't a huge one
they say was an aftershock from
Northridge you just started doing this
it's moving back and forth and I was
like whoa I didn't think it was gonna be
like that I thought the ground would
shake I thought I'd be like like you
feel your feet moving it's not
everything just goes left and right
everything just shifts like the ground
is made out of like it's sand or
something like instantly it just becomes
pliable it's weird
I saw the cat drinking water and all of
a sudden I saw the cat in the air
bowling here that's how much of a dip in
May I heard it looked like you're like
you're on the computer and something and
you yeah and I looked and I saw the cat
drinking water and all of a sudden I saw
the cat in the air and when he landed he
took off and they're supposed to feel
something before the earthquake I think
dogs do better than cats
those indoor cats are done they don't
you bring them in door
runs by them they're like I'm done that
that but I don't think so my pets are
alive and kicking at midnight they would
all they say Kevin look they're like
Judy's how many do you have now three
you only have three
that's crazy you're up to 11 at one
point nine nine I think you're at 11 you
probably forgot I had so many of them
outside I was feeding I had so many of
them oh that's right you had a bunch of
feral ones that lived in the yard to you
Marc Maron has that kind of set up -
yeah or at least he used to it is all
place it is [ __ ] phenomena 3 mmm I'm
down three girls mmm all the boys
punched a ticket my favorite one died
three months ago a little boy now I'm
down two girls so I don't know what I'm
gonna do for my next move is I'm waiting
to see what the smoke clears maybe gonna
German Shepherd out we should all get
out of here no [ __ ]
legit we should get out of here this
should be our wake-up call which is all
just a denver this is a big you know
there's a lot of places like Loveland
hour outside of Denver you know I mean
evergreen 30 minutes outside of Denver -
what what happened to Montana what
happened my town no but here's the thing
Denver's got comedy Utah's got comma you
know what why don't we just open up with
Club of Montana Billings we could do it
that's okay he's opening up a club in
st. Louis everybody's opening up a club
that's if we did go to war with
everybody else comedy school and [ __ ]
we miss Montana if we just decided to do
that when was last time you were month
Oh what did you think I love it there I
love Bozeman what are we waiting for
the winters a [ __ ] those son
winters real bears will listen till now
what is it I realize that we could do
anything he's actually realize look
after every earthquake a certain amount
of there's a certain percentage of
Californians I wake up and say I'm not
going through that again right they get
up and leave there's certain
Californians then go like me they go
[ __ ] you gotta get a generator for my
fat sleep apnea machine and every time
you go to supermarket buy two something
yeah two cans of creamed corn
cancellous you got my [ __ ] garage I'm
good yeah you gotta have dried I'm good
I'm good you know why cuz I'm a child
I'm a child of the 60s when I was
growing up every building you moved into
had a fallout shelter you dumb [ __ ]
nobody remembers the [ __ ] fallout
shelter and they had tang and [ __ ] TV
dinners down there and everyone saw
while your building would run a [ __ ]
thing the Russians are coming the rest
and you'd have to run to the basement
and close the door and they had like a
vent and grammar schools you gotta go
down to the basement and they give you
like the [ __ ] Tang juice and all that
[ __ ] about five children
you coast then [ __ ] yet nobody remembers
the fallout you so I've always lived
like it's the fallout shelter I always
had a back situation I got weed till
[ __ ] tongue doomsday
my family came over here went 6660 I've
been over here already dabbling over
here since the 50s [ __ ] around
numbers whatever the [ __ ] my mom was
doing whatever the [ __ ] my dad was doing
so they were already hip they made it
official in 66 hmm so what I was being
raised here my first couple years in
this country were we were living under
fear Vietnam was going on they had just
killed Kennedy and now they just killed
cuz I was alive and kicking when they
went sit on sehun get killed Robert
Kennedy so it was a different time then
we were living in a little fear Cubans
had pointed missiles at us awesome the
Russians weren't that [ __ ] cool so
that's why the fallout shelter was big
just in case they threw a bomb at us we
go downstairs to a basement live and
stuff like that so I think what [ __ ]
us me was the you all Romero fight deny
the euro America fight I was invited to
a friend's house to watch the fight and
I pretty much had a nervous breakdown
from the fear leaving the house really
because it was cuz the virus yeah
really nervous breakdown you didn't want
to go to your friend's house best guy in
the world you were like I stay home for
people you know I never know I asked him
if they were cool yeah
I know nobody's been to China nobody's
been cuz that's the problem
ya know was gonna in fact look at the
the skier that once gain and New
Rochelle the Jewish guy that went to the
synagogue well the two dudes he went
skiing with I already seen him in
critical condition where they were he
went in a group then he went to the
synagogue in New Rochelle and spread it
all around he should be the most popular
guy in the neighborhood today you know
I'm saying that guy like nobody wants to
talk to so he brought it there from
Italy he went skiing in Italy he
couldn't go to [ __ ] Riverton Wyoming
or [ __ ] Utah or [ __ ] Aspen you
gotta go to Italy like a big shot well
he probably playing a trip to Italy long
before he go to Aspen you [ __ ] know the
Riverton Wyoming that's the best yeah
but he wanted to eat pasta bastard
[ __ ] Utah but before then just drives
me [ __ ] crazy crazy that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] we just can't you well you can't go
to Ajax you can't go to Ajax
nobody wants a ski edge you can't go to
a jail all the way to [ __ ] Italy the
ghost game [ __ ] well maybe he
wanted to go skiing as well as go to
Italy leave me alone [ __ ] bothers me as
it is he took people down you don't have
a passport
you can't leave let me tell you
something going to Italy's awesome I
know it is I didn't say that but he had
a little ski he went to a ski trip in
Italy right but also across in Italy so
you could eat pasta sites you could eat
pasta after and you can see the sights
in Aspen okay do you see them saying if
everybody goes Aspen we're [ __ ]
no Aspen you break it up there's
apparently a guy from aspirin that had
it too
you like it in Utah you like skiing Utah
I don't like skin oh no you don't like
no yeah but they enjoy Utah Iseman they
like all those places we've been asked
and Aspen is beautiful I love it did you
come back with the [ __ ] did you come
back with the hip no there was a guy
okay Leah who had it it apparently knew
he had it and he refused to self
quarantine
he went to restaurants he rolled the
boss he went skiing throw him under the
[ __ ] jail yeah throw him on that see
other thing about the store that that
shocked me that night
Tuesday's to Thursday's packed packed
with people visiting yep for mother seat
from overseas countries yeah so that
started giving me the willies that night
when they canceled the story
I was happy I'm just worried about the
waitstaff you know what like we've been
rocked on wrong the last 10 they've been
rock and roll yeah well they're putting
together some sort of fun too hope they
do it quickly and we're all gonna be
able to donate and there I think they
want to have some stream shows too but I
don't think that's the way to do it I
mean if if they do do it and they have a
bunch of people almost like podcast I'll
maybe that maybe that would work and
have like a telethon raise money well I
say what I thought about this dream
thing I like doing this dream thing but
a podcast not stand up I thought but
then I saw this week with John whatever
HBO John Oliver John Oliver and last
week he didn't have an audience not good
no point of well when no one's laughing
at your mind you need that energy yeah
they were doing live shows from the
Laugh Factory yesterday was yesterday
and it was no audience and I was
watching Jay Mohr on stage for a couple
minutes for had a panic attack and I
shut it off no I just I wanted it to
work
weird and I thought that I could do it
for people just to break the monotony
you know it's like watching someone with
you know voice sing in the shower
yeah no no leave me the [ __ ] alone this
is how bored are we how bored do you
want to go like a 10 o'clock are you
like I'm talking good night yeah no I'm
not I'm not bored my wife goes to bed
the baby goes to bed we iveron a
homeschool schedule they have an 11
o'clock 10 o'clock video conference at
11 o'clock then we do math we take a
breather and she hits the Mitch to
everybody gotta hit the midst of the
house because I get that stress out you
know move they move and everybody's on a
schedule but at night like this is the
FIR
I have not been out of the house and 21
nights no one wanted 25th today's 25-23
nights so at 11 o'clock I get a little
bored think that I'm
the edibles started not working because
you won't been too exposed to him yeah I
just been thought up intolerance I've
been popping to trees you know yeah I've
been eating them so much like the first
like the first week of the week before
st. Paddy's I was I was under so much
personal stress like I was so fearful of
that plane ride hmm
to New York that I was getting [ __ ]
gizelle I wasn't even matched if you
took that flight you would have probably
caught it I mean that that the whole New
York area these are real good chance you
had as a JetBlue by myself cabin I had
it all planned out but the more I
thought about it I'm like I don't know
guys I don't want to be in the hotel I
know how 40 said I know how the
foodservice industry works it was that
very weekend that yo got it the very
weekend you went almost I was the heat
of it yeah that was the [ __ ] heat of
it and it's still it's still just
climbing well they said it's to two
weeks it's gonna reek it reach its apex
but they they have you know an
astounding number of cases they do
however test more than California so
they're more accurate in terms of their
numbers there's more testing being done
in New York City I think by threefold
than California it's crazy man this is a
whole new time and I really hope it's a
wake-up call for us it is a wake-up call
this is Doug listen as jokey as this may
sound or whatever I've always had a
faith my faith got me to where I am a
faith in what a higher power let's call
it a higher power I always had a faith
in a higher power and if anybody knows
about karma is me I'm the [ __ ] poster
boy for karma I know all about it for me
this is like a power letting us know
like it's a reset button take a look
around you guys have gotten caught up in
selfies yeah like you've gotten caught
up in selfies you know you go see a
[ __ ] concert it's two hundred and
fifty dollars and sixty dollars to park
you know you go to a movie theater you
walk out
an American family can't go to a
sporting event no more the normal
American family cannot go to a sporting
event no more without a lot of control
Joe we can't move an apartment or more
1500 for a studio
we just got greedy man the Greed's been
too much you know I got to feel bad for
Disney losing six million suck my deck
you were charging 140 a day [ __ ]
140 a day I think that's the least of
our problems no I think the big problem
is people think this is all this life
the way we're living is gonna be
permanent no no it's changing for a
reason
yeah it's changing for we were getting
[ __ ] greedy but there's definitely
that and we were getting a little
overzealous but we're soft we're soft
that's the big one
and especially we're soft right here
because we don't have to deal with
weather right here we don't have to deal
with nothing you go outside everyday you
could sleep outside and it'd be alive
it's a great place to be homeless all
you need is a sleeping bag get under an
overpass if it does rain it only rains
ten days a year
you'll be fine you know this is this is
a great place because of that but
because of that also we're not humbled
enough you know the places where people
get humble to the places where people
have to deal with direct nature snowy
places real cold places like if you go
to any place that's near an ocean that's
a little slap in the face like wake up
[ __ ] take a look at that you ain't [ __ ]
mountains are another one same thing
like you die up there stupid there's
bears up there's mountain lions up there
they're [ __ ] killing deer with their
face you don't think they'll [ __ ] you up
to go go hike go hiking get lost hippie
you know like it's a wake-up call those
places and I think this is a wake-up
call for the whole country the whole
world is a wake-up call we're vulnerable
and it's also a wake-up call I mean I
can't say this enough people take care
of your health
please it is a one defense for this that
seems to be agreed upon by almost
everyone is that if you have a strong
immune system you have a better chance
to get through any sickness and you can
do something to extract in your immune
system your immune system is something
you can work on you know you can work on
it by cleaning up your diet you can work
on it with regular exercise you can work
on it with regular sleep all those
things have a real big impact on the
immune system also vitamin supplement
with vitamins eat
healthy diet get some exercise and if
you can get in a [ __ ] sauna everyday
tremendous for your body producing heat
shock proteins for your body reducing
inflammation alleviating stress it's
great for your cardiovascular system
it's just great for you there's a bunch
of different things you can do you can
you can use this it's like okay I'm
alive now this is a wake up call
I'm so glad this didn't happen to me I
didn't get wrecked by this I'm gonna get
my life in order and it can be done it's
something that everyone can do and this
is the time to do it this is a good time
to do it if you're surviving and you're
getting through this this is a good time
to get your health in line what you
don't know lot of people don't know
about me is I was a sickly kid
really we never I never believed from
the age of 4 to 6 because my dad died
and my immune system fell apart
it was respiratory I always got colds
always shots you know vaccines I knew
the people by first name at the hospital
at Roosevelt Hospital in New York I mean
it was real with me when I was sick
something else I've asthma
did you really which went untreated like
I just said you have asthma still like
my mother said that's for [ __ ] don't
worry about it you don't need to have
asked me right now outgrew it my
daughter has it though really she has it
and now I see it Mayer and I go
does she have an inhaler yeah and you
don't use an inhaler at all anymore no
did you ever for like a week my mother
goes to get rid of that you live in New
York City you don't smack me Wow your
mother's hard so I grew up with this
[ __ ] thing and then when I was 16 I
got putting off for 13 days for a lung
infection from Paraguay service is then
like I'm not supposed to smoke hmm I'm
never supposed to smoke when I started
smoking I would get sick the days
afterward like I had a jump a hurdle to
smoke pot but when you were smoking
cigarettes what about that that was a
completa not even talk about that but
let's talk about the hurdles I had
smokin reefer early on I would smoke
reefer and it would be an event I would
have to
take three or four days or it would
crush me for that long
well then once I built the Tower and saw
that then I started having to build the
tolerance of who I smoked dope with like
if I smoked dope with me you and Jamie
and somebody else the next day I'd have
a temperature do you get sick from
someone yeah
13:14 so by the age of 15 I already knew
how to keep my [ __ ] like if I smoked
with you and Jamie every day that's who
I smoked with once somebody else comes
into that circle I would get sick hmm so
I had to knock that out so I had to be
very aware at a young age of who I
smoked with I got sick a lot when I was
competing I wasn't taking care of myself
back then I didn't take vitamins I
didn't take [ __ ] I got sick a lot cuz it
was always stressed out too cuz I was
always nervous cuz fighting all the time
so you know you get ready and the weeks
up to a tournament you know that's the
most stressful and the week of the
tournament I would always come down with
something you know and you want a
fighting sick fought sick in Anaheim I
flew out to California to fighting the
Nationals I fought sick I had three
fight sick did we figure out what the
percentage said that was an estimation
that was close to 60% of a sum obviously
it was like 20% those well I think as
time goes on we're getting a better
picture of it take care your immune
system kids I've been drinking a
shitload of water to pee and my crazy
kombucha CB up the oil yep CBD oil for
sure I took some Patsy be deal
accidentally I was wasn't paying
attention I went to the cabinet to get
them some CBD on my man this is tasty
what is this it's like peanut butter CBD
oil and I have three droppers full and
then I looked on it said pet Oh My Damn
hope I'm gonna be okay the differences
between CBD md's pet formula and their
regular formula but I had three full
droppers of their peanut butter pet
formula it was quite delicious it was
pretty good you take a lot I take enough
supplements vitamins Katie yeah I take a
lot of things you know like I said I
down the reef for a little bit
throughout this I was going like through
a half ounce maybe a week mmm joints
among its numb down like 1/8 a week I've
got [ __ ] a couple ounces at the house
go off at a booth I'm enjoying the time
just the relaxing time of no pressure of
things to do you know no shows to go to
stay home every night hang out with the
girls I'm enjoying I don't watch the
news
yeah I was [ __ ] with me the first
week I'm glad that little nervous
breakdown on the 7th that was really
[ __ ] with me and then I said that's
it I went back to my roots I went back
to Boulder I took it back to the Roper
Institute [ __ ] and I took him back to
the meditation so what I would do is I'd
hit the bag 15 and then to come down I'd
stretch and just do yoga poses and
breathe and then and with like a long
[ __ ] meditation and get some vitamin
D I'd do everything outside and back at
the hostel backyard
hidden did I think that hitting the bag
is a kind of meditation yes I really do
yes I think if you really can just
conscious breathing and I know three
minutes thirty seconds off my do try to
do five set to that yeah but then after
that the stretch has really helped me oh
yeah now I have no crowd there opee I
got no acupuncture no spice cryo closed
closed hmm yeah I stayed away from the
last two weeks I did a little nut Nova
tour which is the red lights until about
ten days ago yeah
and then this started getting more
serious and I go you know what let's
start just cutting down this whole thing
mmm and then it's last week and I see
what was going on at the parks and [ __ ]
there's a park close to my house I just
let me go but I can make a few calls
I'm like this is crazy look at these
people packed they're on top of each
other
yeah and if I'm running but I knew that
makes no sense they're all running the
same way are you running right into some
when you're running right into it I'm
Gidi Joe this is what kills me I got a
GED and I'm sitting there watching these
[ __ ] morons run behind each other you
know like yeah all of a sudden you're
[ __ ] Rocky but you're sucking that
guy's breath behind you suck oh my god
and the chick behind you and they all
run in the same direction 10 feet away
from each other so nice a romantic other
cops tell them to a lark
the cops are pulling in the park ball
isn't what are we doing here well you
can be by yourself right
I saw some people hitting the pads at
the park where someone was holding pads
for somebody you did do that we got some
space away from you can get a little
work out there's always gonna be that
good trying to come up to you yeah
there's always that day man aren't you
worried about the coronavirus I have to
take the racehorses out early my
daughter's a race was so at a 45 I give
my wife a break and I just take it for a
little stroll just wear a little wear
out a little bit we play badminton
whatever the [ __ ] that is yeah tennis
with the fly yeah I throw a wiffle balls
either I just only the other days in the
heat of all this I'm there at 9:15 for a
reason they got the playground on sealed
off and then they got a huge [ __ ]
part and for some reason everybody got a
walk I walking between me and my
daughter
dog by the second person I had to say
something really really you can't walk
around you gotta walk in between people
can't have enough they passed your
[ __ ] wits
well they don't they don't change their
behavior the best was the guy that
watched me playing with my daughter and
I could see him out of the corner of my
eye Gerald and I could see him I could
see him whispering to the wife some
stupid [ __ ] and what does he do he
starts walking towards me and I'm not
even paying attention to him but I am
I'm watching them through this [ __ ]
vision mm-hmm I'm watching him I'm
playing with my daughter throwing the
wolf football and he's walking towards
me finally had to stop and he goes hi I
just wanted to [ __ ] I go stop
he just looked at me and I felt terrible
for but this is what's actually going on
they still want to shake your hand yeah
people try to shake your hand still they
still want to shake your hand I'm like
it's not gonna happen
stop right there yeah I go hit me on
Twitter now it's your back but that's it
I don't want to hug I don't want to know
nobody nothing you gotta tell me I want
to hear yeah unless you're showing in
here with a [ __ ] envelope which I
don't see you have don't come close to
me at all people did they're not
changing their behavior though that's
something baby there's a number of
people right so some people pay
attention to everything
some people are over cautious I went to
the [ __ ] supermarket this lady had
goggles on and she had I mean not
goggles but big jackie onassis dark
sunglasses a [ __ ] face mask with
these giant gloves on and she's walking
away from everybody like everyone's a
bomb and she's doing her grocery
shopping Michael you've gone too far
this is a little ridiculous
and then I'm looking at other people
that are acting like there's nothing
wrong when they try to shake your hand
and then there's people that are paying
attention too much so that they've
become paranoid they're not even living
their life and then there's other people
that aren't paying attention at all
they're barely paying I'm in the middle
I'm in the middle I know I have to live
my life that means I want to go to
7-eleven for nothing yeah 7-eleven is
filthy I don't have to go in there for
nothing okay nothing I got rolling
papers and everything in my house why
this I got lighters till next morning I
can light myself up ten times with wide
as I got I'm not you know I'm not
putting myself in a bad position
ya know you've been quarantined Jamie's
been quarantined Jamie I didn't go to
[ __ ] you know there's somebody instead
tonight there'll be a concert no go
where no if I tell you that tonight
there's a concert they'll go if it was
if it was Liberty University's letting
students back in today Jesus is gonna
look out for him yeah there was an
article on CNN they were showing Liberty
University opening up its doors again
students like this just started you
[ __ ] you can't just you know what do
you think we are right now beginning yes
yes you don't think you look good till
mid May no listen it keeps accelerating
every day but it's accelerating everyday
that means it's at the beginning
every day there's more cases every day
there's more people getting sick
doesn't he say yesterday I don't quote
me on this he's talking about Easter
yeah because it's a very special day to
him see he said it's a special day this
virus doesn't give a [ __ ] what day you
think Jesus came out of the ground this
virus doesn't give a [ __ ] and if you
don't respect it people are gonna die
and there's people like the lieutenant
governor I think is who he is of Texas
who is like we should take a risk with
older people just to get the economy
back in line
people like whoa what are you saying you
think the economy you should we should
get the economy back in line and by
doing the economy some old people are
gonna have to die
you've ready to sacrifice people for
money yeah older people would rather die
than let kovat 19 harm US economy Texas
officials said older people would rather
die that's what he says lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick okay yeah and you
know he was saying that he's in that
high risk category himself because he's
70 you notice these politicians are
terrified that this is gonna lead to an
economic disaster and their names gonna
be stuck on it you know I think they
were terrified at first that they had
they had to act that a closed things
down but they didn't have a plan and now
they realize like oh my god this might
have to stay locked down for a long time
what happens the economy yeah you didn't
have a plan no one had a plan so they
locked everything down and now they're
like listen this could last a long time
we got a fig we got to start the
rumblings now of getting this ball
rolling again because if it's goes six
seven months and no one's working no one
can go outside their house for six seven
months like this is crazy
what we won't have any money and China's
gonna take over Tucker Carlson had this
whole piece he did that I saw that was
actually pretty accurate you know where
he's talking about what what could be
possible do like he was talking about
how the NBA did you see that whole
segment where the NBA they had said
something about China and then then you
see all these people that were praising
China and saying positive things about
China what was this what was the reason
behind that Jamie your MBA guy the GM
for their Houston Rockets tweeted like
support for Hong Kong that's right
that's right was support for Hong Kong
and then China got pissed at that and so
then they started tweeting nice things
about China and they started well at the
time if that happened that the there was
like an MBA teams in China doing games
and we just come back and then they
started asking all them what they
thought about this and then like the
Bron started supporting China I think
and then everyone jumped on them and
like like money over people I think well
you mean that they face consequences for
supporting Hong Kong yeah well what
tucker carlson was saying in his piece
was that imagine if that's the the whole
country like understand that like if
china's the ruler of the world of china
becomes the ruler of the world not the
united states because of something like
this like this is all really possible
like the idea that the united states is
the ruler of the world so it has to stay
the ruler of the world forever no
natural disasters disease [ __ ]
asteroid impact there's a bunch of
different things that could shift the
balance of power in the world rome used
to run everything right the you know the
there's europe england the UK you see
England used to run to half the [ __ ]
planet there's a lot of different
countries that were on top of the world
that are no longer on top of the world
and we would be in a real sticky
situation if we had to live under the
same military dictatorship - China does
and the idea that we would never have to
live under that we we can't where
America well that's ridiculous because
we're human beings and other human
beings are stuck in a circumstance where
they're living under a military
dictatorship so there's no difference
between them and us other than culture
and the place where they live that that
shifts things change with natural
disaster with disease with failure of
the economy with war with all these
different factors things change and our
perception much like our perception of
our society itself it's always going to
be like this and all sudden this disease
comes along as it shuts everything down
you're like whoa that's a [ __ ]
wake-up call
need to recognize that this is kind of
fragile well the whole system is fragile
if those things happen natural disaster
disease war anything catastrophic
happens the balance of power completely
shifts and who knows whose control the
survivors are under who knows who knows
how this works out this is all real
touch-and-go right now this is real
touch-and-go this is uncharted territory
where we have slipped into a place where
no one's working and everyone's scared
and the president wants to go back to
work on Easter because it's a special
day to him and Joe Biden can't talk the
guy was running for [ __ ] president
for the Democrats can't talk did you see
they were deleted the latest [ __ ] Tim
Dylan sent me two videos he's like what
the [ __ ] is going on like he's in a
cognitive decline governor in New York
Cuomo put him in put him in coach
put him in you want it you want a guy to
run for president that makes sense you
want a guy who's an intelligent guys a
strong leader who's got a lot of
experience and press the [ __ ] out of
middle school that's the [ __ ] out of me
too what he's like putting up human lies
more than money he's impressed me I tell
you who else is impressed me I don't
know
see you can't say nothing because you're
always gonna be wrong there's always a
knock well but Joey you're wrong because
he's declined the woman's abortion Act
there's always something that's true
that's part of that's that's the
argument they had about I don't even
know what it is I don't even know and I
tell you it's always or something I
don't even know what the issue is late
term abortions he apparently voted for I
know there's always something so and I
was just making a joke but I know you're
actually the other guy that's doing a
good job but I see that he's
communicating this is governor Newsom
yes he's doing a great job I don't know
what his politics are I don't know if
he's a democratic or republican I just
know he's stepping up and he's fighting
for these people and he's making some
smart choices and you know what I don't
know it you a [ __ ] scientist Joe
Rogan let me check are you a scientist
no me neither
go [ __ ] ourselves until that time I
don't know I do know one scientist and
she's telling me to stay the [ __ ] home
business mmm I knew no I dunno three
four people work in emergency rooms that
have told me it's not a [ __ ] pretty
place no my brother's a cop in the
marina in a hospital and he says that
it's a [ __ ] nightmare that you have
to sort them out a and B and B is if you
have kidney itis and a is if you have
Quran Verona they say it's a [ __ ]
nightmare right because you gotta think
the same amount of people are still
getting injured yes and certain other
stuff so Mercy's coming in hope is
coming in they're not corona ships yeah
they don't want no corona people doing
that they just want [ __ ] you know
they're bringing in a ship with a
thousand beds there's [ __ ] these
goddamn cruise ships you want to talk
about a petri dish stuck on a metal
craft in the middle of the ocean breathe
in recirculated air with a bunch of
people partying around you is the ocean
and if you fall in you're dead because
they don't scoop anybody out when do
they ever turn the ship around scoop
somebody out when they fall overboard
did you ever go on those cruise [ __ ] oh
no chance for comics that was always a
death sentence I made a mistake no when
I was 21 with a chick no one of the
cruise ship the one that used to go
around Manhattan so you leave at 6
o'clock and you're back at 6:00 in the
morning
and they take out far enough so you can
gamble
yeah a blackjack I did that one one time
nice but I knew I wasn't gonna do it
again
got out of my system
I'll only go on a [ __ ] cruise ship
yeah there's economic I hate you hate to
say this is a comedian amongst us it's a
death the death sentence for me they
have additional work I do gotta say
though the [ __ ] Impractical Jokers
those guys did a tour on a bus I mean on
a boat apparently everybody loved it so
it's like if you get your fans in there
right a rare thing right yeah there's
people that could pull that off
yeah yeah well Alonso goes on jazz too
he doesn't does jazz cruises you know
Londo Bowdoin Alonzo Bodden is a serious
jazz fan loves jazz music loves him I
love him to death he's always been the
best Clippers fan before anybody even
talked about the Clippers I ride a
motorcycle everywhere yeah that
[ __ ] badass bike yeah he's got a
bunch of bikes one BMWs mm-hmm but he
was a Clippers fan when they were all
192 he was down it by himself at Castel
Alonso now he's living like a doctor
he's [ __ ] yelling soon as they got
climbing I was happy just for a long
time that's how much I love Alonzo that
I was happy just for a while
everybody nobody has a beef with Alonzo
nobody no why would you
first little break-in ass she's giant
his [ __ ] hands a ginormous he's a
sweetheart he's a sweetheart
he doesn't even know I could break him
baby never you'd never know that he's 6
foot 4 250 pounds solid muscle or
whatever the [ __ ] he is he's a tank of a
man but he's just he's hilarious too
he's he got he he's a dude it's got
great points like here's one of his
lines he said he goes not every Trump
supporters racist but every racist is a
trump supporter there's not a whole lot
of racist voting for Biden I mean maybe
a few they can't let that guy run for
president they have to put his op he's
gone you have to see these recent videos
have you seen it Jamie
and then you [ __ ] killed Bernie
Sanders you basically killed Bernie
sighs they can't read that Porter you
put the kiss of death bottom [ __ ]
oh my god Julie or the Puerto Rican
chick oh shut up okay she oh oh she's a
Puerto Rican chick that that she was 28
years old she won't show thanks to
riches congresswoman she's like [ __ ]
I won't talk to him because the Joe
Rogan backed them well it's not
instead they used a video of me to
support their campaign to say that I
endorsed them and then they took a bunch
of my bits and they took a bunch of
things we said on the podcast high as
[ __ ] out of context and made it look
like I was some right-wing monster make
them like I'm some sort of homophobe
it's and then they use the trans folk
thing from that the variety that you
still yeah man yeah if you don't know
the story used to be a man for 30 years
became a woman for two and then started
beating the [ __ ] out of women without
telling them that her whole life she had
been a man up until recently she just
thought it was a medical condition that
she didn't have to reveal and I got mad
domestic violence yeah it's crazy it's
it should be criminal to not tell
somebody they mean the idea that you're
the same thing as a biological woman is
just not fact it's not scientific fact
and yeah I said a bunch of horrible [ __ ]
about her that she's a not even horrible
[ __ ] that she I just said mean things
that she's a man like you're a man you
can't you can't just go fight he said
the truth yes that's why I did I said
the truth and I said I'll have a lot of
friends but here's the thing I'm a guy
that I support bull riding okay I
support if you're a woman you want to
fight a man I support it but you gotta
let that person know that you're a man
you if you used to be a man you got to
let him know if you wanna if a woman
wants to fight a biological man right
now a guy with his balls and she wants
to do it and they and he wants to do it
and they sign off on it you could
skydive why can't you do that they're
both the same wait go ahead I don't
think you should if you're my friend if
you're a woman and you're my friend I'd
be like there's too many physical
advantages it's too dangerous
all they have to do is hit you once you
said they don't have to be as skillful
as you if they clip you you're [ __ ]
and that's the truth
that's what happens I mean it's a giant
advantage doesn't mean the woman can't
win because Germaine de random II
actually had a kickboxing fight with a
man and knocked him the [ __ ] out that
went that lady's a beast the Iron Lady
from Holland she's a beast but she's a
former UFC featherweight [ __ ]
champion of the world means she's an
animal that lady and had a real close
fight with Amanda Nunez recently for the
bantamweight title she's a one of the
best fighters on earth and she beat a
man and knocked him out
but you shouldn't fight a man if you
don't know it's a man that's rude and if
you didn't know that someone used to be
a man that's rude too so they tried to
pretend that I'm not this transphobic
Crusader I love all people I literally
love all people I don't care what you
are whether you're gay or straight or
Asian or black or white or I don't care
I don't care I just if you're nice I'm
nice to you that's I'm a hundred percent
open to everybody but I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you can't fight women if you
used to be a man and not tell them it's
so ridiculous that that's that's even a
debatable subject like I had a bit about
it where I said never do it I think as a
society we could get to a point where
someone would say hey man I don't think
it's cool if you get your dick removed
and then beat the [ __ ] out of chicks and
people be like you're out of line that's
where God that's where it god we got so
overly progressive in the the fight to
do the right thing we got to write that
script about a guy who falls in love
with a girl it turns out she's a man
she's really hot you're still into her
do you really care it's a good question
ya know that's what some people don't
care some people ugh I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm right or die with you Hugo
when you're alone with them her in
public
yeah man it's um in the fight to do the
right thing and that's what what's going
on with progressives when they get
overly progressive they think they're
fighting to do the right thing but you
have to be able to call out [ __ ] that's
wrong on your side and this is one of
the problems that the Democratic Party's
having right now with this Joe Biden guy
you guys got to be able to call it out
you can't let this slide cuz everybody
else sees it and Trump is going to eat
him alive he's gonna eat that guy alive
the guy can barely remember what he's
talking about while he's talking do you
know which one it was cuz there's a few
videos there's a few of them play any of
them they're all Rick they're all crazy
every video of him recently talking he's
stumbling through [ __ ] he forgets what
he's talking about
we should be making those masks we
should be moving on those ventilators we
can do that why doesn't he just act like
a president that's a stupid way to say
sorry he's done no no I probably best I
don't he's like Junior soprano yeah it's
not that's the that's not even the worst
example that's just an example the one
down there when he's talking to that
lady I think that one was a struggle too
that was a struggle fest
and people at home are you at all
concerned as Trump says yeah this is it
not let the Cure be worse than the
problem itself we have to take care of
the cure that will make the problem
worse no matter what no matter what we
know what has to be done we know you
have to reassess the recommended period
yeah see he doesn't know what he's
talking about when he's talking and this
is not like this I'm looking at this
like a medical condition okay I'm
looking at this like okay when I'm
calling a fight and I see a guy limping
and I'm like I think he heard his name
Thiago Santos against John John's I
think he hurt his knee there I think
there's something going on with his knee
like that's what I'm looking at this I'm
looking at this like this is a medical
issue that's not a normal way to
communicate unless he's high as [ __ ]
because if I was high I'd be like I
don't know what I just said to this lady
blasted or edibles going what are we
even talking about I don't think that's
what it is I think he's he's oh he's
very old I think he can't he doesn't
look good either and they got makeup on
him his skin is all pulled tight like a
lizard
he's got the button Governor Cuomo
that's I loved his behavior I loved his
attitude so [ __ ] and he's been honest
and I'm telling you if less you're a
[ __ ] idiot just go to any street
corner in New York you know looking
[ __ ] footage from July light
it's too many
it's too many people it's to go I
couldn't even think about get on a ferry
gonna either Rudy's like I was staying
somewhere on Park Avenue and I'm like I
gotta get into an uber which I'm [ __ ]
filthy okay when you walk into an uber
people are sitting in cars with the
windows shut breathing whatever he's
breathing
yep I open up the car and listen you
guys are you gonna get in yeah give it a
minute
and then take my handy wipe out and
lower the window and close the [ __ ]
door but why not it when I get on the
ferry I stand outside I don't sit in
there I breed that Hudson River and
that's good for you that's as good as
it's gonna get affected all those bodies
and [ __ ] floating in there that [ __ ]
maluca dust in there and pollution
whatever the [ __ ] is in there
but I know look at within weeks Teaneck
right t-mac was one that got
contaminated a Fort Lee got it
you know that's all my [ __ ]
neighborhood dog I don't think nobody
Hoboken was really bad
Hoboken come the cops out of going there
[ __ ] Hoboken was like a party my call
Balkan didn't give a [ __ ] like they were
[ __ ] just having orgies in Hoboken
Geno told me you got to say it really so
they finally had to go down and they
closed Oh bulken like you weren't a lot
to go into Hoboken only people who lived
in Hoboken good party in Hoboken then
they just had a [ __ ] to shut it down
somebody had a meme on their page but it
might have been Darnell I forget who
what no madman snoop I don't remember
who it was but anyway they had a meme on
their page that said you tell people
you're gonna put them in jail if they go
out after 8:00 p.m. but you're letting
people out of jail early cuz they got
the corona virus and there's someone
going hmm
like what like what the [ __ ] what are
you saying are you gonna lock people up
but you're letting people out you know
if if you looked at this whole thing
there's been some weird people of God
test they got tests I think I tested
there's been some weird I don't even his
Bahamas [ __ ] who mr. bike it just his
business whatever his [ __ ] name is
angels Elba yeah the black dude that got
shot well he lives in England and he got
tested because he was in contact with
other people that had it you know why
the [ __ ] that Harvey got a test cuz he's
in Rikers and Rikers has a massive
outbreak no yes
yeah he's in Rikers he's in maximum
security he's in Buffalo now do they
move into that because of the corona
he's in a hospital in Buffalo he's fired
he's [ __ ] he probably has no will to
live
you know I mean he probably doesn't have
a will to get through this I mean I
don't know what kind of medical
treatment they're gonna give him but
this could do him in easily it's running
rampant he's so sick already
you look at the guy he can barely walk
his health is deteriorating all that the
stress from this trial killed him
crushed him took 20 years off his life
instantly this is just a death sentence
why don't you I was just saying we were
talking about this yesterday imagine if
you came up to him four years ago and
said I want to show you your future
dying in a bed in prison for things
you've already done right now you're
walking around toast of the town getting
in limos climbing out people are waving
to you and cheering you're getting
interviewed on the carpet everyone
shouts you out I just want to thank
Harvey Weinstein for his amazing amazing
company and the movies you put together
that allowed me to shine yeah how many
people have you seen all the people that
that praised him and then four years
later imagine that he thinks the things
he's already done he'd already done them
at that point and they knew why they
were praised I wonder what they knew
they knew they knew scumbag selling it
they know yeah you got to assume they
all know so what the [ __ ] yeah they went
back they knocked on doors wait a second
so I rape you you go to that party what
do you mean so I raped you at a party
now the next year is gonna be another
can festival and you're gonna show up
again because they wanted to work see
the thing about Harvey is apparently
this is Whitney Cummings take on it she
said he would actually give them the
things he would tell them he would give
them so he'd say hey you
[ __ ] my dick I'm gonna make you a star
and you would actually do it he would
actually put them in these movies he
would give them what so they were happy
so they would get all this treatment and
they haven't spent some a long time with
him every now and then so they would
send him emails lovey-dovey emails but
really they hated him and that's when
all this came out he didn't even see it
comment cuz he thought that they loved
him he thought that they would send him
these emails so he sent the emails to
the press like look look at all these
emails these girls love me even though
he had done scumbag [ __ ] to them it's
just he had it set up where this was how
you got by this is how you made movies
this is how you want to be famous this
is how you get famous I can help you get
famous you got to help me get rid of
some come today everyone I thank
everyone did all the guys do really
every guy because he will feel real
intractable apparently oh I don't know
man one of the people said the producer
did not have symptoms and was under
close observation was not clear why he
had been tested on you there's a lot of
[ __ ] that don't sound right to me
they don't give listen in vick's are the
last people they care about
yeah alright and the only problem you
have with those things you could really
sue the state like I got locked up when
HIV was starting to get popular 87 88 so
as soon as I got to my destination they
had already built an HIV unit that was
[ __ ] state-of-the-art facility
everybody else lived like a [ __ ] Momo
the HIV guys live like kings microwave
ovens TVs yeah they let them get
microwaves oh they had everything in
there how come their own refrigerator
because they didn't want their food they
didn't really know oh yeah yeah of the
HIV so they had their own thing they had
an old cook that came in and cooked for
the six guys in that unit so you never
know I don't understand
that must have contributed so much to
homophobia but okay
when you not in jail I mean in the world
you know during the AIDS crisis what do
you mean
homophobia in the world during the AIDS
crisis when AIDS was was out when it was
a big deal I mean I was almost too young
to remember because I was like 21 when
it was happening I was still a kid
but I mean the people that were already
inclined towards hate and gay people and
then there's a disease that everyone's
terrified of that you get through sex
that could kill you and it affects gay
people disproportionately 83-82 those
were tough years you know they even made
a good phenomenal movie about it called
and the band played on mmm with Richard
Gere and a bunch of great actors they
Richard Gere played the guy that the
[ __ ] the guy that's a choreographer
that did a bunch of plays I can't
remember his name
oh yeah he played him in a in like a
weird manner and they everybody in that
movie was a movie star it was a
phenomenon worried about age at HIV HIV
really started with a stewardess a male
stewardess that would take flights from
France or Italy or England ones don't
quote me but let's just go with France
to New York he would come to me [ __ ]
somebody from the plane then go to the
studio 54 and get his dick sucked and
then go right back to England and he
kept doing that it was all sex with the
same stewardess really if you watch
watch that and the band played on people
forget about that was gonna put that out
in this week I never saw one of my
weekly movies excuse me Jim you see if
there's a trail afraid of something and
the band playing I'm really can't play
the trailer
no no but they'll tell you who's in it
oh and you're gonna go damn everybody's
in it like everything was such a it was
such what just um go to the the movie
don't go for a YouTube don't go to a
trailer just go to the movie on IMDB
look he was there he was still swinging
dick beautiful and these guys were all
gay and he's going to interview gay
dudes they got it and that
on the man we it started with a spot on
my hand and this is a phenomenal
phenomenal movie if you've never seen it
so there's the starring there's the cast
Matthew Modine from Vision Quest Alan
Alda Wow Matthew Maule Dean Nathalie
Baye Christian got being [ __ ] Phil
Collins Alice Courtney David dukes
Richard Gere there's somebody else in
this that was that that was back in the
day when rocks John Huston was great
Glenn Healey was greatness see they're
all doctors yes Richard Gere was a
choreographer it doesn't say which
choreography it doesn't say but it's it
supposed to be somebody who was very big
at that time who's a see who was
supposed to be based on Jamie yeah the
actual choreographer the real one that
it's based on right but find out who was
supposed to be based on Phil Collins was
in that movie it's interesting like the
rock stars used to be these do movies
back then remember gene Simmons get did
a few movies he was phenomenal gene
Simmons did a movie called with the dude
from oh my god the bomb in his mouth
Oh Rutger Hauer Rutger Hauer that's
right
wanted dead or alive [ __ ]
gene Simmons did that one who was a bad
guy where gene Simmons was brilliant was
on Miami Vice when he played the coke
dealer on the [ __ ] boat in the pilot
for this second season he was
phenomenally played an Arab he always
played an Arab they made him take a
suntan
they told him gene go be an Arab and he
would [ __ ] get a suntan and wanted
dead or alive he was an Arab terrorist
and in Miami Vice he was like an
international Arab arms deal and he
hooks up Crockett and Tubbs he'd little
ton of work and felt Collins did a good
Miami Vice to week we kyra sedgwick
who is what's-his-name's wife now he did
a tremendous episode Kevin Bacon Kevin
Bacon there's a lot of great movies from
that those that era that I'm putting
them out gee that's it the other it
started like March 4th
for me by mistake at about 11 o'clock I
caught on because my wife changed
something at the house so they threw a
different epic Alice some package and at
11 o'clock death wish we started and I
watched you from the beginning and now I
know why rape and all that [ __ ] is
disturbing to me it's that movie oh
right I may be saying that movie is
little kid [ __ ] my [ __ ] up wasn't Jeff
Goldblum yes the one tools that rape
scene in that movie [ __ ] me up so I
started watching my mom a lot more nasty
those movies got campaign like the death
wish movie started out the real first
one was really kind of disturbing and
scary disturbed and you were with
Bronson you're like go get him oh no no
you were with Bronson at that time I'm a
New York had had a vigilante the Jewish
guy
Berkowitz mmm the one that got on the
train and shot the two black yeah yeah
because they he felt intimidated by
right we shot one in the back right New
York was kind of in a [ __ ] a little
bit of a uproar I don't know death wish
was first or that movie was first but
death wish is [ __ ] the rape scene is
so [ __ ] disturbing you want to cry
and that's a kid I haven't been thinking
about like my mother at the bar like
this could happen to my mother oh this
could never [ __ ] happen I don't know
yes this Jeff go boom yeah absolutely
right
yeah he was he was real scary and it to
who's real creepy yeah this is horrible
[ __ ] man
does this has happened to people before
that's real Charles Bronson was a bad
[ __ ] in that movie too you
believed he had those shark eyes though
he went to Arizona to try to relax after
his wife died or his wife was a
vegetable and that dude game was done
took him to the gun ran and that's when
it was all [ __ ] over
he just went out at night looking for
[ __ ] to shoot okay I got a good
movie that people forgot about which one
Southern Comfort how good is it it's a
real good movie remember the movie no
bunch of guys are doing there in the
swamp I think it was Louisiana and
they're there like National Guard
guys they think they're being cute and
they run into these backwoods swamp
people they live back there and then
wind up getting those Creole those
French dudes let's speak French is this
it yeah man so they they run into these
communities of people that live deep I
guess like Cajun people am I saying that
right it was that wrong some what it is
and they get [ __ ] up and it's it's
they get sucked into these guys world
they think they're being cute and they
shoot at someone or something I forget
how it happens but they wind up getting
[ __ ] up by these guys and it's scary I
haven't seen in a long time
I enjoy the [ __ ] out of it when it came
out though 81 freshmen in high school
it's good [ __ ] no I remember this movie
yeah I remember this movie yeah yeah
yeah booth what's his name again booth
you know what's the first thing I forget
he also played TK Kirkland's in that
movie it could be the stand-up yes he
could be he was in a lot of movies man
he was he was in the John Carpenter's
The Thing yeah remember that TK Kirkland
was a lot of [ __ ] movies see the um
what's that cast Jamie Travis booth said
his name No is that right I am you know
it's uh played the dude in Jonestown oh
yes that's right that's right he does
powers Boothe that's right keith
carradine that's right
who else is in there can you show me the
is it is TK TK Carter not quickly to
take Carter sorry TK Kirkland I've
[ __ ] up that's I blame the weed TK
Carter used to be around the store all
that used to be around a store great guy
yeah he was a great guy
damn I haven't seen him in forever right
he was always doing he was doing movies
while he was doing stand-up and then
wind up just doing these big ass
movies when he was in the thing I
remember good what year was the thing 82
so he was in the thing when I was in
high school
crazy so what time I came out here I saw
him like six years later yeah it was
crazy when I saw him at the story no it
wasn't that 82 so 10 12 years later 12
years later I was out here so was 12
years after that Southern Comfort it's a
good movie but one of my all-time
favorite movies all-time favorite that
nobody talks to us a movie called 29th
Street what's that it's a movie about a
guy named Joe Pesci and then you know
who he is he's the guy in real life and
real life Joe Pesci was the dude and
Beverly Hills Cop he was like the token
Italian for a long time well that guy no
that's limp ugly oh that that's Joe
Bosch this movie is a [ __ ] phenomenal
movie oh my god this is Danny Aiello's
best [ __ ] movie if you got daddy
issues you do not watch this movie it
dis so Joe passion real life the brother
sold this movie as a script he's he's
great friends with Sylvester Stallone
Stallone puts him in all his movies now
he's always old and all the Sylvester
Stallone's movies but this guy's name is
in fact that black dude so when I came
to the store this was one of my favorite
movies of all time it's a guy it's a
movie about a guy who hits a lottery
ticket in New York City he wins the New
York state lottery ticket the first
lottery ticket of all times true story
that actor in real life one that guy on
the run right there yeah he's the one
that's a Vinny today's your lucky day
yeah my name is Carmine [ __ ] oh he was
he's also that what do you think I stole
that line from who you think you're
dealing with Joey bananas that's um
Beverly Hills Cop he's the one that's
Eddie Murphy this [ __ ] hmm and then in
the beginning of beli Hills Cop he's the
guy that has the truck
daddy Murphy's going to rob he's had
great with the scenes like he had that
one with Beverly with and then he was in
Midnight Run with when [ __ ] they've
made the Niro go look for the guy the
guy that they made go look for De Niro
is sitting one of the tallien got it's
Hancock running yet Midnight Runners De
Niro and the guy that with the bad hair
piece [ __ ] great movie Dennis Farina
just an Academy Awards but one of the
Veniero's best movies because he had to
be he had to do comedy that guy Charles
Grodin oh this is a class Dennis Farina
is the best gangster in the world oh
that's right and De Niro's caps room but
there's a dude miss this is the dude
that they hire they look for the vero
whatever happens that Charles Grodin guy
he's still looking for Jays killer he's
still looking for the killer cold that's
who he's looking for he's still mad love
Jay they finally threw him off TV the
wig company wouldn't sponsor Moe didn't
he have a late night show he had
something he has something they that the
bomb would movies but back to 20 [ __ ]
ninth Street so funny not when I first
moved to the LA the black dudes from the
29th Street came into the store one
night and I was like who is it
well played he's a drill sergeant that
movie he played anthe because Frank
Bosch wasn't in real life wasn't when he
sold the script it was a beautiful
script but somewhere along the line
somebody had to sit him down and go
little bro we love you story we're gonna
shoot it you're not gonna play you man's
nap so they had Anthony LaPaglia who was
already a star in his own way he's
Australian Anthony Lombardi is he really
yeah he's Australian
that's amazing yeah he's Australian
they're so good at doing our accent yeah
he's tremendous so they let him be the
lead
dan al played the fall
he played the brother they still let him
be in the movie got a great role you had
a great role the Italian woman that's an
airy movie played the mom I don't even
know what the point of the [ __ ] story
it's just a great movie like Joe Biden
Midnight Run 29th Street that treats a
great movie midnight Roger I would see
all these guys at the store
alright guess who else in the 29th
Street who Vinnie curdle no [ __ ] yeah
he's deke he's in the scene with Paulie
walnuts mr. Prado and one time he's got
to come in and go
have we ever told the Vinnie Cordaro
story I don't know
Vinnie Curto was that close made with
Robert about that he also was gonna
fight [ __ ] you boy at one time who he
was scheduled to fight your boy who's my
boy the guy from Boston I'm the black
dude with the shaved head from Marvin
Hagler yeah that's right yeah yeah Vinny
kurta was a [ __ ] animal when he was
fighting he was an animal then I saw
many kernels in it and then he curdled
shows up at the store and somebody else
was in it
I'll get him hanging out with Sam
Kinison I I met Vinny right when while
before but right when all that [ __ ] was
going down I went to his apartment and
he was show me the script and telling me
what was the Marquis Walberg that's when
he was gonna hire funding fell apart
like last minute the funding fell part
in the movie deteriorate but it was a
good movie he had based on his life his
life and it's a [ __ ] up story you know
and he was he was willing to to say who
he is and you know how he became who he
is he was a tough [ __ ] though
that guy was a tough fighter very I read
his other script and it's better than
that
his scrip was good it was a very good
scroll the other one he wrote about when
he had to go hide out in Canada so he
couldn't go to any training gyms really
ever been to where he was looking that
they were all looking in boxing gyms
while instead of hitting the bag he
decided to run up a hill in Canada it
was very hard to run up this hill so
every day he would rob the hill and
finally there was a kid in the block and
he had some type of muscular dystrophy
and the kid always I like to walk up
that hill
so they said listen before you die we're
gonna walk up the hill one time and he
walked up there on the way back the kid
died oh just he and he rolled into a
[ __ ] screenplay Wow Vinny's got some
stories he's got some stories but he's
got and he forgets him I mean how many
fights do you know what's another
Academy award-winner I forgot about that
I'm gonna be honest with everybody right
here I refuse to watch it when it came
out riffing years I refused to watch
what and after I did I'm happy I did
Harlem Nights is so [ __ ] good Harlem
Nights Eddie Murphy is such a [ __ ]
black experience that it is a
masterpiece I mean I've been watching a
lot of [ __ ] lately and I haven't seen
that in forever what year was that I
remember seeing it when it killed is so
[ __ ] Pryor oh my god oh my god [ __ ]
with the other [ __ ] guy - Redd Foxx oh
my god this is such a good movie get
that picture I refuse to go see this
movie I'm like this is just black
exploitation it's so [ __ ] brilliant
this movie
have you seen Dolomites yes I haven't
seen it the new Dolomites I heard it's
amazing I think it's amazing
I heard it's amazing I think it's him I
think he did a great job and just he
says one line that movie I tell you that
I love I fell in love I had tears coming
out of my eyes he's an open mic man and
he's [ __ ] dying to make it and you
know how we are and one of us comes up
to you later Joe you know like he's
right
I think I'm gonna do this and the other
committee was like man he is a bum and
he you know like when you're at that
when you're an open mic and you really
can't and he was walking away and he
said Thomas to somebody goes it's gonna
be alright and Eddie Murphy does not hey
man there's nothing worse than having
something to sell them nobody to sell it
to and it made me feel like an open mic
because that's what you feel like when
you're an open mic yeah you get but
nobody sell its it do you member that
feeling when you'd watch someone on
stage and the crowd was packed and you
just wished you could get up there right
now and that's I'm trying to do right
now I'm trying to reform during the
break yeah I even wrote the story out of
how I like I was lost and my ex-wife
[ __ ] forced my hand and drove me to
the Comedy Works in Denver and how I got
offstage and I was like this is it and
I'm like but the only obstacle has a
wife and a kid we just bought a condo
how old were you 28 it stole my soul
like it just like I didn't want to go to
work no more nothing else mattered the
only thing I loved as much as doing
comedy was cocaine like nothing else I
just like cocaine and stand-up comedy
and I couldn't figure out how to do them
and make a living and pay for a family
then she came home after three months
issues he want to be married no more and
part of me was 80% relieved him the
other 20 I wanted to be a father and the
whole thing but it's a truth I fell in
love with it it [ __ ] just stole my
soul like I didn't I knew everything
they had I watched every tape I studied
Carlin I studied the [ __ ] out of Pryor I
studied the [ __ ] out of dice I studied
the [ __ ] out of Bill Hicks you know I
loved or ex you know I watched today I'm
before I came up here I was in a rabbit
hole cuz I took my daughter for a walk
and I sat down from it to get them a
drink to send some emails
and Rodney Dangerfield was on The
Tonight Show
the week before easy money and he said
that uh he still he said joking The
Tonight Show and I was laughing I
thought it was funny he says he drinks
so much he pissed on house a night that
was on the other night Caddyshack oh the
beginning was on I watched that far
that's a great movie so like this
vacation whatever the [ __ ] is going on
it has been rough on me at all the first
week was rough on me before st. Patty's
Day when I thought I had to fly to New
York was rough on me I already had a
plan already in mind I'm coming back
from New York and I'm just staying at
home I'm hiding like a [ __ ] that
was my plan for how long I do not know
Joe if he says the 18th I'm not still
going out for 20 I have a 4:20 show
yeah I'm for 20 show in Vancouver but
it's on the 18th or 420 420 Monday night
Monday yeah that's not happening I don't
see how it can happen unless they come
up with some sort of cure in ten days I
mean it's the 25th unless somewhere
around the first week of April
they have a cure that's not gonna happen
yeah I mean there's there's some hope to
some treatments that they're coming up
with there's no cure right now there's
no vaccine it's not even close your way
plus how big is this place that you
doing I'm doing an arena and what how do
you feel doing it like do you feel I
don't want to put anybody at risk okay
if if people can go to the show and have
a good time and not be at risk I would
love to do it's a weird man if the flu
was going around I know this is worse
than the flu but if the flu was going
around we wouldn't think twice of doing
a show
it's what's so weird about this it's
like it is absolutely more deadly than
the flu don't miss read what I'm saying
but it's just so crazy how different our
approaches to this as approach to
anything else that winds up killing
people you know we've all known people
that have died from a disease
diseases there they kill people all the
time but we've never been in a situation
where everybody's scared of one disease
it's so strange man it's so strange and
I don't think I could be able to get
past that and just do a show right now
I'm 90% sure they're gonna cancel it I
mean the the stuff that they're coming
up with for treatment one of them is a
malarial disease and old malaria disease
there's some other different treatments
that hold hope and but there's so many
people man that could get infected if
you've got a show of 12,000 13,000
people whatever it is how the [ __ ] are
you gonna make sure those people are
okay is it your responsibility do you
say come at your own risk you know I
mean what if you get it when you're
there like what are we doing what are we
doing you know I mean well it's the
whole thing's crazy it's I think it's
gonna be a long time before we feel
comfortable doing shows again it's gonna
be strange at first you know but I'd
also think when the dust settles it will
settle hopefully unless this is the
first thing that falls and then all
those other things fall into place we
talked about natural disasters and we're
gonna appreciate peace we're gonna
appreciate freedom you can appreciate
being a roam around do whatever you want
go out at three o'clock at night you're
gonna you gonna appreciate it you can
appreciate being able to go to a diner
and have breakfast with your friend the
two o'clock in the morning and laugh you
can appreciate it
cars on the street everybody acting
normal it's gonna mean more to you now
it's like the Sun after a rainy day it
means more feels better has more of an
impact and I think we've gone through a
long stretch in this country where
everything was static everything was
doing fairly well we were on an upward
trend no real tragedy national
nationally to change the way we live our
life other than September 11 so we got
like September 11th and then all these
years of war of course crime of course
always say but we're basically business
as usual for most folks not anymore
is a wake-up call it's a wake up call
that you have a finite amount of time in
this life and this life the way you're
experiencing it right now it's this is
just how it is right now there's a
million different factors that are in
play constantly and you've been real
lucky
this stretch of peace and harmony but
that [ __ ] could change at any moment it
really could and we got to use this time
to be nicer to each other we're gonna
use this time to realize that we got we
got a little confused we got crazy you
know everybody's just trying to acquire
things and everybody's trying to you
know move their way up the corporate
ladder like hey there's there's a
[ __ ] end to this ride okay this ride
comes to a stop someday and it doesn't
matter how much [ __ ] you've acquired it
doesn't matter you know how far you got
up this ladder you know what what
position of prominence you have in the
community and how you're respected by
the business world nobody gives a [ __ ]
when you're dead it's not you're gonna
die we're together right now
experiencing this thing in this like
really distracted way the thing comes
into focus when you're forced into a
situation like like we are now where you
literally are nervous about your
survival then the thing comes into focus
and you're what to me my gratitude is
coming to focus my gratitude towards my
friends my gratitude towards my family
my gratitude towards you know look we
were very fortunate that we're not
living check to check you know many of
us and many of us have been in the
comedy community many as many of us are
now there's a lot of guys listening to
this right now that we're hoping for
these weekend's coming up so they could
pay their rent this is uncharted
territory for those folks and all of us
that are experiencing this but the
people that going check to check they're
the ones are really getting hit know
that you cannot stress over this and not
that your stress makes you get sick yeah
weakens your immune system we are work
you know and I know 50% of people are
being honest you know my friend said
that they yanked them the other day for
the cable you know cable doesn't give a
[ __ ] so they show this cable off they
will they call them and tell them they
were shutting this cable because I had
the money I didn't have no problem with
it
my wife just we have to pay this so
they're just jumping on people right
away
yeah they jump on you right away so yeah
they didn't want a stack I don't know
how landlords gonna be I had another
friend who said this is really funny Oh
God divorced ten years ago close to
eleven years ago there was a dispute
with one of the credit cards during the
divorce 4,200 bucks coming out of the
[ __ ] woodwork yeah chasing down cold
cases cold case isn't [ __ ] like that
yeah they realize a big effort whatever
money you have if you didn't pay your
student loan they might yank it now just
jack it from you yeah I'd say we had to
do this right so be very [ __ ] careful
you're right you know all right and you
think about it that way who knows what
the [ __ ] they're gonna do they're
telling you on TV yeah this landlord
isn't gonna care
first off listen if you can't do
business I can't take your rent money
but Who am I gonna put in there anyway
who called you this morning incidentally
gone to look for a location for a
business and if you have two brains in
your head you're not doing anything
right now
no you know buying the house unless is
your business like unless you drop and
buy houses for a living even if you do
you'd be like let's hold on here nothing
for the next six or seven weeks you
don't know dick I've never even thought
about the China thing I didn't read that
article but that was even enlightening
but you don't know dick mind your
business you don't got it I don't have
to fly nowhere do you understand me yeah
I'd like to go anyway I got Brea
the first week of June I got
Indianapolis and Cleveland somewhere in
there and June that's it I got nothing
July July 31st I got Las Vegas who knows
what's gonna happen there and August 1st
I'm in San Diego who knows who knows of
any of those days I'm being smart about
this listen so what you mean to tell me
is that motley crew who was supposed to
start a huge tour in August
Guns and Roses who were supposed to
start
massive tour in June they're all pushing
their stuff back to October and November
December I mean when Live Nation thinks
about giving that motley crue money back
they have a heart attack
they have a heart attack there I know
yeah well hold on to this you know cuz
it's August
I talked to salami he talks to
what's-his-name Ricki
I think it's August that they go on tour
so what are you telling me that right
after people a lot to go out people
gonna start going out and spending money
right away
I don't think so guy I don't think so
they're evaluating every day we're not
at work every week that we lose the
width of that 1200 I'll check that
tomorrow
that's what one I'll check is basically
gonna get people groceries I think that
right now like where we're real
touch-and-go but shows the rest of the
world right
China's touch-and-go everywhere is
touch-and-go everywhere Italy certainly
touch-and-go they still got their
streets locked down you know who knows
what they're singing that night they
don't give a [ __ ] just singing like no
then New York's got act like gay people
they got a [ __ ] sing Yellow Submarine
more sing war pigs [ __ ] this is New
York this is the boogie down bronx what
are you singing Yellow Submarine for is
[ __ ] for mellow submarine yeah all right
you know what's killing me the most
about this there's one thing about not
wanting to go out and do commie there's
another thing that you can't go out
right okay I'm the Captain Kirk of the
enterprise you know what man I gotta get
out of house every three nights so if
not somebody's gonna get stabbed you
know that even a belly room show I don't
give a [ __ ] there's always something for
us to do you know how long anything is
gonna be I guess honest what I'm seeing
today by what I wants in the news last
night I think for me to go back on stage
it'll be May first
I don't know when I'll be on another
plant again don't-don't-don't yeah it's
all guesswork right now we've really
really have no idea how is your focus
been on writing have you been focused
enough to really write the best stuff
you've been writing right now no yeah no
okay
I've written it all okay I haven't
written at all while this is going on
I'm winging I'm tried I've tried to
write I've written jokes they're like
you know the funny thing was like last
week they had that poor little white kid
that the rosy cheeks mm-hmm he's like
you could tell that dude never got a D
in his life you see that video you know
this is doctor yeah yeah this is our
turn in Florida you know yeah like I had
to write about [ __ ] like that like yeah
everybody's mad at that kid jump that's
me right that was me and my EP maybe one
eighteen year olds yeah can you imagine
come up to me and 81 and gone where's
the coronavirus I would have snorted
we're here to party I want to take give
me a line that coronavirus watch nothing
happens to it give me two lines I
guarantee you you know so it's all
different that could have been us that
kid was a dumb as a [ __ ] stump did
you see that poor his parents must be
like Jesus we [ __ ] up with that dummy
this one girl was like is my birthday
turn up oh my god there was like 20
little chicks are doing that [ __ ] me
breaking heart dance to each other ones
breath oh I was [ __ ] dying that's
hilarious
the achy-breaky heart dance yeah
whatever I don't know what dance is
don't quote me the fifth grade type [ __ ]
goddamn so I don't know what the [ __ ]
going on you're always gonna have that
with kids though kids are gonna [ __ ]
they're 18 years old they're gonna [ __ ]
they're going out they have a couple
drinks in them they got plastic cups
they're gonna fart what about the dude
who took his
certainly and he got the [ __ ] herp
when he was over there he ain't they
Bono Mack so now they're both busted
disgusted he took his mistress to [ __ ]
Italy to do something and they both got
the Corona oh yeah and they got detained
over there somewhere something up Oh
cats out of the bag mama file for [ __ ]
divorce she's got nowhere to spend the
money [ __ ] Manhattan shut down
yeah there's nowhere to go in the world
like the UFC's talking about putting on
a fight on April 18th you know I don't
know how they're gonna do that I don't
know if they're gonna be able to do that
in the United States they're talking
about doing it in a place with less than
ten people and then you know they're
just an open arena I guess someone's
gonna commentate it it's not gonna be me
and they're gonna be duking it out like
in an empty place and they're gonna try
to do that on the 18th they did it for
the last card in Brazil because it was
ordered by the government the government
ordered all large gatherings to break up
when they started seeing the cases of
Corona rising in Brazil so they had to
do the Brazil card indoors no people
weird so but they're gonna plan could be
Antonio this way they're gonna plan it
so it doesn't even have to be a big
place they could do did it like a film
studio like legitimately they could sit
they could set this up in a film studio
somewhere I mean they could Tyler
Perry's got a place in Florida they
could good on a Florida rent one of
Tyler Perry's gigantic film studios set
up I mean we did it in when we did fight
for the troops when they did yeah yeah
San Diego and several other places in
Austin as well whenever we did it
there's a few birth carrying there 'he's
a few different ones that we did they
just would use an airplane hangar and
the troops be there that they would be
the whole audience was the troops in
their uniforms and they would set up
this octagon in an airplane hangar and
it was pretty powerful
it's different different real different
different kind of show but they could do
that they could
do that in a studio or just a large
warehouse UFC could do it set up some
lights have some crazy high-speed hook
up to the Internet
well it's party notes getting uploaded
and we're watching it from here I mean
that they could definitely do that the
UFC has the capability of doing that the
thing is how they're gonna make sure
that nobody has it you know you're gonna
have to test everybody and if someone
has it do you let them fight like what
if they have it and they're like Idris
Elba they have no symptoms but they got
the corona like what if khabib as the
corona or what if toni has the corona
just khabib you can fight him this fight
is so [ __ ] cursed there's places I
gotta be honest with you I gotta be
honest with you I already that's one of
the first things I thought of would say
started talking then they started
talking about the NBA game can feels
this is why Dana's trying so hard to
make it happen even if there's only ten
people in a row at first for a couple of
days that was mad at Dana my [ __ ] day
now I go you know what this fight has to
happen this I don't care if this happens
by itself in a [ __ ] airport in Havana
Cuba
mmm I don't give a [ __ ] but this fight
has to get over with we've waited so
long how many cancellations three quite
a few three for you
this is the fourth time three or four I
think this is the fourth hospital visits
broken me yeah
anxiety might be the fifth this might be
the fin oh I think so yes I this [ __ ]
curse google it
how many times has Toni versus could be
been canceled I'm gonna say I think this
is the fifth time it's many times though
and it's the best fight then they they
kept giving you know first the NBA then
the next tested positive yeah then the
[ __ ] city of New York went under and
I'm like all no everything's pointing in
the wrong direction I go but don't have
Vegas then Vegas said then I [ __ ]
March 20 this is the fifth it's the
fifth I walk in time come on this has to
happen
it is the Phi don't care about any other
quite
just pay them Dana just pay them just
one fight just pay them one for I'll pay
the paper don't warm ups I'll pay the
6950 pay-per-view just to see khabib and
get it over with could you imagine
that's it nobody nobody else has to
fight
6900 one fight one two three trainers in
each corner that walked in eight yeah
one guy and we'll you'll put the [ __ ]
judges they watch from home listen that
terrible one there there they tell me
one of their terrible win that ass
yes I'm gonna help them be in there you
often times you honestly you get a
better view of what's going on when
you're watching at home okay so yeah
especially headphones on so when I watch
with headphones because I'm watching
like when I look down at the screen
sometimes when I'm watching fights I
have to sometimes I get a better view I
can't see what the [ __ ] is going on
there's pillars in front of me you guys
are grappling and I don't know if
someone's trying to get a submission or
what's happening sometimes guys tap and
I didn't even see it was like what did
he what do you do I don't have to like
break it down then I have to look at it
on the screen when you're watching at
home often times you have you really
have a better view of it but this is
doesn't it's not as crazy alright so we
we don't need them they're within social
distancing we already here you could put
them in a [ __ ] judges can all come right
here I'm gonna look over the shoulder
come right here and then so all we need
is the three guys in the corner yeah two
fighters the ref Bruce Buffer
test Bruce Buffer Bruce Buffer he could
do a long distance no no no he's gonna
do with a gas mask on Bruce Buffer was
gonna be in there red face with a
[ __ ] school but helmet on does it
have to be pay-per-view do you think cuz
there's no class for it of course it
does really know what are you a
communist no socialists trying to get
[ __ ] free show same time you're
talking about passing on stimulus checks
how are you the UFC wants money I'm sir
how are you gonna get people to pay for
you're gonna get plenty of people like I
said you know what saying I Jamie wants
everything to be somebody [ __ ] loses
here so you gotta be a douchebag
somebody loses her because how am I
gonna put all this
there's three or four prelims five free
limbs and then for fights before that so
I'm talking ten fights I'm talking
twenty people three per whatever their
trainers that's a lot of people Joe in
one [ __ ] place of winner so it can't
we got to eliminate their early prelims
and just do the main card they could do
that but everybody also I'd have to test
everybody everybody can not share a
space either I cannot be in this room
with you all Romero without throwing a
sidekick because he's about to fight but
if everybody's tested and everyone's
negative then who gives a [ __ ] that
should be the only thing like if you're
testing your negative but you should be
able to wander around
I think this [ __ ] is a creepy
[ __ ] the virus yeah I think
you're right I think we're gonna find
out more I think that could be a 21 day
something I'm somebody waiting hear
about what about the people who got
stuck at Texas Airport last week four
hours of the luggage when they came back
internationally there was O'Hare to Ohio
last week nobody's testing positive from
waiting on line eight hours yeah if you
go on Twitter everybody who's dying is
from functions of the coronavirus right
and you can join a virus
you had it going that line so I got to
see how long this could really stay two
weeks ago they were saying the stamp the
air droplets stay in the air for [ __ ]
three hours now I don't think they have
a lot of reliable information yet they
have some they know what it is that
snack have you seen the corona virus on
the rap song no I got it on my Instagram
page you haven't seen it no great these
guys it's really catchy I started I
start singing it throughout the day
sometimes I'm driving around what you're
doing it for me
no I'll play it for you I have to play
it can't even play it now and one get a
copyright strike will play it afterwards
this is the world we're living in I
think people are less less worried about
[ __ ] right now more worried about
real things I think in that sense some
of my favorite people that I've ever met
are people from Israel something about
them they like carefree my friend Shuki
he was a kick boxing trainer in Tarzana
Majuro gym and Tarzana nice to go down
and train with him there and he was from
Israel and I went to eat dinner at his
house once he invited me over his house
was family and there playing bongo drums
dancing and [ __ ] they were having so
much fun they were so happy and I said
tell me this I go why why're Israeli so
like carefree it goes because every day
over there you can die every day over
there you can die he goes any day
something can happen and he goes
everybody just while you're alive you
want a party party party have fun have
fun have a good time and I was like wow
that's it they have a heightened sense
of appreciation of life like my friends
all my Jewish friends that would go over
there for whatever religious thing they
would go would talk about how hot
Israeli chicks were like the chicks in
Israel they're wild while and they all
have to go to the army oh yes he was
stuck that was the old show they got
stuck there while [ __ ] missiles were
flying - what the [ __ ] is that that's
right that's right
yeah yeah it's uh we got we were looking
for trouble
instead of trouble being here our life
was so soft we were looking for trouble
where it didn't exist we were trying to
create problems where they weren't they
weren't real we were getting outraged
about things that really didn't matter
and now we see what matters so now that
focus has to be on real real survival
things and health and community and
taking care of each other and looking
out for the people that don't have any
money right now because they're not lazy
they just got [ __ ] you know we got to
look out for each other right though all
those things
coming into focus now instead of the
nonsense that people have been fo what
you eating there what is that okay I
thought it was aspirin or ibuprofen I
was gonna say don't take that [ __ ] why
not
shouldn't take that [ __ ] right now
ibuprofen is a non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory and it can do damage
to your gut bacteria apparently you can
[ __ ] with your immune system what
ibuprofen
it's advil stuff like that's good if
you're you know you need it if you're
injured right but it has an effect on
your your your gut biome and it causes
inflammation on some people cam Hanes
was on that [ __ ] every day he was taking
800 milligrams every day and he was in
all this pain and I sent him this Rhonda
Patrick thing where she was talking
about the dangers of ibuprofen and and
taking large doses of it particularly
like all the time and so he gets off of
it he's like [ __ ] like there's danger of
stroke see if you can find the dangers
of taking too much ibuprofen because
there's a lot of people that really get
into that I'd be prolonged I take a baby
aspirin at night that's fine that's it
that night I think yeah I go to bed
because so I'll be protected between
5:30 and 12 which is the highest rate of
having heart issues ibuprofen is very
different than what so you know cam runs
like 20 miles of the FDA strengthens
warnings that non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories increase heart
attack and stroke risk yeah that's
that's like Advil it's non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories there's a bunch of
different ones motrin advil naproxen
Aleve ibuprofen
yeah that's ibuprofen and naproxen so
two different types of non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories ibuprofen and
naproxen they're both available
over-the-counter and he said it's
important to be aware of the ibuprofen
warnings and the proxy warnings and take
steps to limit the risk so cam was on
800 milligrams that [ __ ] a day right
he's in pain all the time because he
runs so much gets off of it and the pain
goes away so he's taking something for
pain and it's causing him to be in pain
all the time because it is causing all
this inflammation because his
gut is reacting to this [ __ ] chemical
he keeps dumping in there and it's a
vicious cycle because you've got all
this inflammation and that's what's
causing you to take the [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] is giving you the inflammation and
he's thinking the inflammation is coming
from his running so he gets off of it no
more pain like god damn we're so
ignorant so my initial guys who's an
elite athlete means the guy who runs
ultra marathons he's run as much as 240
miles in one race right and he didn't
know like how many regular folks know
that this stuff is bad for you how many
regular folks take unnecessary
medication that could be beneficial to
you if you have a real issue but he take
it all the time he'd take it too much
and actually causes problems this is a
wake-up call for people when it comes to
your health a wake-up call for taking
care of your meat vehicle take care of
your body you got to take care of your
body this is one that if you're
fortunate and you have a strong immune
system you you can mitigate some of the
effects of it and that's the case with
the common cold it's the case with the
flu it's case with a lot of different
things if you're healthier you have a
better chance of coming out of it on the
other end you know moving on the flu
shot
never so I just found out recently that
I could take it doesn't work as good on
older people though no we asked dr.
Auster homeless I can never take it
gonna has needles involved you could
touch I would love to do heroin once in
a while but to get really high and I was
a needle that's where you throw me the
[ __ ] out that's where the party ends me
once you say needle that's where it ends
for me so done yeah um you got a great
joke about that I want to say it right
now what's that you about needing a flu
shot but it really is the truth that it
is I've just I think the immune system
we've we flown so much
we have flown so much yeah that that
bills
different type of immune cells we did
like at the Chicago theater and giant
places where we took pictures with
people after the show hundreds of people
you know I just did the Treasure Island
sold it out and took pictures of
everybody else's show that's a lot of
people went back up to my room and took
a tremendous hot hot boiling shower you
know the last time I was at the store I
always take a shower before I go to the
store mm-hmm the last time I won April
2nd yeah I was probably the first time
in years I took a shower that night
that's how disturbed I was like I was
[ __ ] really disturbed from that last
time I was at the store yeah because I
thought everybody else was going to be
social distancing more people grabbed me
that night than ever before and every
time they grabbed me or somebody came up
to me and talked to me
my skin was crawling I'm like I'm not
coming down here for a while
yeah there's no social distance an
thirst or no so I was following any
rules over there I was like man this is
my [ __ ] spot but now look not him
live without which is crazy you're not
gonna live without and that helps
sometimes like I said not doing comment
I give it a breather and or not being
able to do County two different [ __ ]
things yeah I can't wait to get onstage
I have a ton to say you know we all do
the last [ __ ] four weeks we've made
ourselves laugh and now we lose our
[ __ ] minds
yeah I'm one of the reasons why I
haven't written anything is cuz I'm just
enjoying the relaxing me too
it's been too long we've been doing this
too long but and the last run this last
nine years has been a run it's implied
cast well once you started really school
you started really kicking ass on the
road - yeah you really picked up your
pace you got it yeah you got it gotta
make hay while the Sun shinin as they
say no but you got it you got it right
there's a car you got a right well I
felt like um with this I wanted to think
about it because I look I'm I'm one of
the you know I love one thing that max
Holloway always says says it is what it
is and it's a simple philosophy it is
what it is but it's also it's a good way
of looking at things
it's like what are you gonna do you're
gonna freak out it's not gonna change it
it is what it is and this was this
what it is right now it is what it is
we're inside all day you know if we go
outside we go outside for a hike there's
no people there you know come here stay
away from everybody no hugging no
kissing everybody just distance and we
do our social distancing and we wait it
out and just this is life right now
we're still lucky we're still not look
Justin ran comes here a couple times a
year after he gets back from the Congo
okay and Justin goes over the Congo he
sleeps in a grass hut and he's come back
with so many different [ __ ] diseases
he's got malaria three times now we have
so here's some new parasite that they
don't they haven't identified they don't
know what it is
he's worried it's in his brain because
he's having some shakes and some chills
and some some issues that lead him to
think that it's connected to whatever
the [ __ ] this parasite is so they keep
running tests on him they have these top
biology virologists that are examining
him but he's deep deep deep deep deep in
the Congo so who knows what the [ __ ]
in there there might be some new [ __ ] in
there he might literally have some new
[ __ ] in his body right now and you know
this guy keeps going back he goes back
because he's compelled he's his his
mission in life is to improve the lives
of all these people that he met there
it's changed his perspective you know
he's an amazing amazing person and he's
constantly doing that like that guy is
so happy and so friendly and I think one
of the reasons why is because his
perspective like he knows what it's like
where these people live he visits them
he stays with them for months at a time
he knows what it's like and he knows how
lucky we are over here we're lucky as
[ __ ] so right now we can't do stand-up
you and I are extremely fortunate we
have podcasts you know so you could just
do your podcast instead of what do you
do it two days a week do it three do it
three you probably you'll be fine
you little give playing chances to rant
rave I only have people over the trust
you know no one's sick don't touch
anybody wipe everything down wash your
hands take a lot of vitamin C eat
healthy take all your vitamins make sure
you get good rest get in a song
if you can please get in a sauna they
have them I mean I don't know if they
have them at gyms [ __ ] you can't go to
gym good dick nobody's got a [ __ ]
soul get in there get in the hot tub
then nobody knows where the [ __ ] goal
of a photo that everybody has a sauna if
we have on your lies I got a cry I wish
I could do a thousand things but you
can't they were also saying one good
thing just elevate your body temperature
just elevate your body temperature like
by working out and breaking a really
good sweat you know the data actually
has a good effect on your immune system
as well even if you like exercise in a
hot room you kick up your immune system
you have to do anything crazy but what
you're doing is you're you're
introducing those cytokines those heat
shock proteins where a bunch of layers
and get a get a little decent workout
and really get hot sweaty it's good for
you
all that stuff's good if if you look at
like the first thing after benefits of
working out it's always lowering your
stress working on your blood pressure
yeah this is the opposite this is the
times right now a debilitating that yeah
there were like if you went to a queue
boy if I had the ability to acupuncture
right now I know he'd tell me like oh
all this [ __ ] is well they they make you
grab the thing well this is low like all
your chakras a block like [ __ ] like that
all that [ __ ] is probably running low
like you need help with your immune
system
yeah even though you haven't been doing
much because just the subconscious
thought that thoughts that we have now
you know we start to say this [ __ ] goes
deep into your subconscious that's what
happened to me that's why I had my
little nervous breakdown on the night
that your Romero fought
so tell me you had this is you were kind
of getting into it you were your friend
invites you over his house to watch the
fights and you're like I can't and you
had a breakdown having me over like
Wednesday and I'm like absolutely if not
I'm just gonna sit here at home and
watch him by myself like I always do or
I'll go to Brett's house all right you
know Brett yeah right
right that night he called me like on
Wednesday he was really doing Saturday
I'm getting a catered a couple people
coming over love for you to come over he
broke his leg skiing Oh No so when he
break his leg skiing three months oh
sorry oh oh no [ __ ] metal in his leg
no main dog so I was young crutches
still yeah yeah he just got off maybe a
week ago oh what a time to have just got
off a [ __ ] surgery when this [ __ ] is
going down yeah you beat the surgery
curve like by three weeks four weeks oh
my god
imagine I'm okay all day I'm with the
family [ __ ] six o'clock comes I gotta
jump in the shower
it's basically where he lives jump over
a little Kang and make it right go a
mile past the Comedy Store that's it for
some reason man I wanted a shower in the
shower I just started getting an
irregular heartbeat I came out somewhat
to the war anxiety medication got
dressed what are you taking
they give me a 0.25 whatever I don't
take them what is it zanuck zanuck it's
a football it's the baby want it's not
the [ __ ] the junkies take its so you
got a little anxiety so you took a xanax
and so I took how often you take those
things most of the time between you and
me I wash them my wife washes them much
as I put him in my drug pocket and you
forget they're in there and I forget
they're in there like prom in the hamper
on the mire so between you and me I
watched more than I and I only get like
he gives me if I ask him he'll give them
to me I asked him fine maybe two
prescriptions a year you know so just
keep him around just to keep him around
just what does it do
I've never done I just in case I get
that Morgan Murphy freaked out I got
Morgan Murphy freak what's her name
what's her name Morgan Murphy yeah yeah
I had a follower at the store I know
what it was that [ __ ] walked up the
stairs and my anxiety lit up
really I almost passed out but I went up
there and destroyed the room I came out
of a fog at the 13 minute mark I didn't
know what a lot of my mouth I didn't
know you wrong Zarek's or anxiety just
things I did something up there and I
just got this weird anxiety and I
remember reaching over to Pauly Shore
Polly can you go up there for me I can't
do it [ __ ] you I got so [ __ ] mad and
I went up there leveled it but I was in
a coma I was Levi no no my body was so I
had so much anxiety it was just I was
just spewing I was like Roseanne Barr at
night saying [ __ ] I was just talking
when I got off the stage Pauly Shore
told me you should get anxiety a lot
more often I just worked myself up you
know you work and I worked myself up
that much that night I wanted to see
your Romero I definitely want to see
Joanna against Ching whatever whatever I
was young I was young I wanted to see
her so and all this another Joe Rogan it
was I wasn't getting a stroke I was
gonna take mushrooms and not eat them
but I was gonna take mushrooms with me
and my jacket how long you know I would
have only within the car pulled the car
the driveway what like six steps stop
the car and then sat there for 10
minutes deciding whether I should take
the mushrooms I'm gonna get stopped by
the cops I had no idea bosom mean no
nothing there was no reason for this
paranoid it was just my mind playing
tricks on me I started walking in the
house thinking I was gonna about to have
a stroke I couldn't control myself
should I take the keys I know I forgot
something you weren't I
No let me go get the [ __ ] xanax just
in case I get a [ __ ] shy bring an
edible now I will bring edible yeah yeah
probably go back inside and get it
edible
how is that that was my acting oh my
gosh wear this shirt I should wear a
different shirt anyway this year well I
just went through this whole [ __ ] and
I finally said stop Joe Diaz get your
[ __ ] together [ __ ] so this is when I
turned your Diaz yeah Charlie's go let's
go [ __ ] we're gonna go let's go
come on what are you [ __ ] Buzzi what
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] I got in that car
that they're like mainly down okay I
went over there he had some Yub for me
with some Lobster mashed potatoes and
[ __ ] and we just watched the fight we
had a great time there was a dude that
was turning me on to medical [ __ ]
telling me the [ __ ] inhale silver Oh
block the [ __ ] block the [ __ ] thing
yeah yeah it was great but you know what
that night I realized I was just having
a [ __ ] this can't happen no more
hmm that's the type of [ __ ] I like to
avoid I don't like that I said the first
time I got high I took another bone with
the jujitsu and somebody mounted me by
mouth please get off please please
please get off me please I had to go
outside take my gear off and take my
dick out and pee in the street as far as
my bar that's how bad yeah I got a pee
right away it's like when I go lift on
Mondays and Thursdays I go live for the
train when she puts 400 on the swamp
machine and I got a [ __ ] squat as
soon as I put the back I gotta go babe
she's like what are you going I go my
body just wanted to shock my body just
wanted to shock that's how you could
tell and when I gotta go I gotta go
my first three months in jujitsu I
learned the hard way never take an
animal no bueno
don't be taking a Hannibal at 10:00 in
the morning go Jiu Jitsu at 6:00 it
comes back hmm
even if it's gone it revisits you the
first time somebody threw a mountain
me dog had one of those heavy judo Jesus
hmm I didn't even know the lightweight
geese yet oh my god Joe Rogan's I had a
call a time out like it was over had a
run outside take my chi almighty top off
and just take my dick out and piss cars
are gold by Burbank Boulevard I'm just
peeing I don't give a [ __ ] about the
cops I tell them the truth I get these
huge anxiety surges yeah well I work out
heavy like heavy weights I gotta go to
the bathroom before and before I get my
car I think how long does that ain't
does the medication help you when you
taking a xanax
not if you don't take it right buddy you
got [ __ ] to do in the daytime though I
got no time for a [ __ ] xanax I don't
know what does it do that's what I'm
asking well I'll tell you what happens
with Zanic so I know for a [ __ ] fact
that nobody could tell me when I first
got into comedy how I go it'd be as the
secrets of comedy you ready okay when I
got into County all these jerk-offs you
gotta bring five people to a [ __ ]
show I'm not asking nobody to come to a
show I just wait for Joro gonna call me
and ask me and once a week you want weed
meet me at the comedy club I gotta meet
you the county so don't worry about it
just made me there next thing I got you
pay and tell at the door so I got into
selling xanax there was a crazy guy in
Boulder it just gotten out of prison for
the murder and his wife I don't know
they were getting xanaxs from the
pharmacy so I was getting valiums the
v's the one wouldn't be you know
anything ten milligrams you could sell
those with two bucks apiece he was given
to me for like a corner so when I first
was an open-mic ER I was an accessory
but it always cuz I got into a contest
so for me to win the contest I had to
have people there so they would say when
can we buy some zone if you gotta meet
me at the broker so I would make that
all of them will come up Mingo but what
the [ __ ] wrong which I just paid that
Mouse to get in it
you got think they're off the price of
the pills don't worry about it I got you
covered
I had such a high profit margin it
didn't really matter so I would sells a
next
people in the hundreds twenties tens
cokeheads love those things so what was
I was a cokehead
I love I could eat 10 of those what does
it do not you the [ __ ] out like how like
you're gonna pass out you could die like
that one people Obie that's what they
eat [ __ ] xanax and they [ __ ] I
thought it just relaxes you it relaxes
you but if you eat 50 of them you're
gonna die I was eating 50 you eating 50
and a day dog hey thirty of them in
three days in Beaumont
it took me five days to recover yeah I
told your L Dean in Beaumont Texas in
nineteen in 2005 for me in thirty ten
milligram valium that's a lot the
problem with that [ __ ] me as you ready
this is what I realized twenty thirty
years I was an open mic I was selling
them I was David shake that didn't dude
didn't get high so for me to be around
it I would pop those Annie bars and I
would be I'd be good enough for me so I
was used to popping like six of them
I had my tolerance up their [ __ ] high
and bonds you liked it because I would
drink with them I would drink like one
or two drinks you feel tremendous that's
it just wanted to like how do you feel
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] up two drinks and
a couple zani bars you get [ __ ] up
this is before there's Annie blog you're
not supposed to drink on them right no
no but I walked up and then I do call me
any twos to valiums and drink with the
waitresses I was an open mic a guy right
you know but the point to my story is
that if you eat ten milligrams of Valium
five of it your body utilizes five of it
the other five go into your fat and your
body holds onto it usually there's a
science you forget are you dealing with
here so what happens is when you eat
that [ __ ] it sticks into your fat fairy
tale I would get high [ __ ] not the
xanax would come out of your favorite
agitate the fat and [ __ ] it
it would educate the xaniix out of my
fat if you jog would you get high oh
[ __ ] yeah
does your body start so go for 12 years
at the 7-year mark I'd be working out
from find the time and I'd bump into a
coke rock it just went through my system
and I get all paranoid and creepy for a
minute like I was still digesting [ __ ]
right the years by it I believe that
those bars and all those little is
anything sticking to your fats and then
they get me tired the next day yeah
don't get me tired now like if I eat six
or longer tied one of them I mmm
I don't need them until and then
sometimes I remember to take it out and
put them in back in the thing sometimes
I just draw them in the hamper one of my
friends would take some says that when
you get off of very highly addictive
well he also said that when you get off
of them it heightens your anxiety like a
rubber band effect that's what he was
saying for him personally
I'm gonna tell you what I do realize
what these [ __ ] things these things
are the worst things I ever they hear
things does it just the worst thing why
because my hearing was better before I
got these really you told me something
once that when you're doing when you're
doing the jack when you're doing the
bye-bye nyet to get you stronger that
your nutsack disappears so when you go
off the by Bonnier if you're doing
steroids your body's endocrine system
shuts down so it no longer produces
tests dogs is that true yes you both are
your balls shrink is that true no the
balls don't really shrink okay so but
they don't work anymore since this is
not putting any work I feel with this
ever since I got these hearing aids to
clarify my hearing mm-hmm it's made my
hearing weaker it doesn't make my
hearing is it true words anymore
I mean aware of the fact that your
hearing gone bad no my hearing was not
going bad Joe Rogan I was hearing things
out of place I was hearing the wrong
thing
I went to dinner with Joe Rogan it was
fine of you and I had a conversation if
you brought your wife I'm gonna have a
hard time that restaurant you weren't
here I wouldn't hear nuttiest I would
just hear Jamie's table on the other
side of the room I could hear his
conversation more than yours really and
I could hear this the silverware hit the
table and I can hear the dishwasher
washing dishes and every time his Fork
would hit the [ __ ] thing I hear that
[ __ ] every time I four kids at a
restaurant I would be every time I was
at a restaurant if it was me and you
having a good time what'd you throw Ari
and Duncan of the mix I'm just basically
yes in you to debt really yes that's how
bad it what is that called was her name
there's a couple different names for it
you know and then somebody told me they
kind of had it I go why do you wear
those no like I don't know fees I went
to concerts to the point where they
heard too many things I just needed to
narrow it down hmm so I finally figured
out what these I don't have my mom low
does it not you hear [ __ ] everything
like I was getting high and [ __ ]
hearing everything you get yeah you get
high you [ __ ] hear everything so they
have these new air pods now that of uh
they have sound deadening so it's uh
they sit in your noise-cancelling so you
put them in and you can either turn
noise canceling on or you can turn them
into transparency mode and transparency
mode the microphone actually picks up
the stuff that's outside
have you tried that yeah Jamie yeah so
it makes things sound louder than they
are like you can hear things better in
the way it seems to me you know I don't
have any hearing issues to people that
maybe to have you don't have hearing
issues whatever it might make it sound
better yeah
yeah I don't have any hearing issues but
when I put those things on I could hear
things louder I can hear stuff like
further away it's like I don't think I
can hear them talking if it wasn't for
you know noise cancellation works
there's microphones on the outside that
like flip the frequency and it cancels
it out oh that's how it works and so by
flipping it over it's just adding to it
hmm does it what is the number this is
like one and a half times louder than it
normally would be
is there a no when you add three DB
which is not a lot that doubles sound
that's like it's the intensity of the
sound is more it's double D it's really
hard it's like a math quick equation
with sound it's interesting because
that's one area where Apple has just
stolen the show when it comes to Apple
versus Android like phones are pretty
comparable I haven't tried them but I've
heard that Samsung maybe has a galaxy
bugs
close to it or they're very people like
them also they're very good but they
don't have the sound cancelling they
don't have noise cancelling and the the
Apple ones did I think the sound quality
has been reviewed as being better to
their they just they have they figured
out how to make it like you you just
open it up right you pull it out of your
pocket you open it up but it asks if you
want to connect you press button boom
and connect stick it in your air and the
air perfect and for me it's so much
better than a hands-free system when
you're driving in the car I just have it
in my ear and a double tap on that
instead of it going through the whole
car and hearing it in the speakers and
everything I just hear it in my ear like
I would a normal normal conversation
that would have with air pods on there's
another level you could probably get
into that I don't think you have any air
monitors which I know like Burt has yeah
Tom and Christine you have those at the
UFC when when I go into the Octagon I'm
doing an interview I have a ear monitor
and you can get really good ones for
music they have like eight different
speakers in that little tiny thing yeah
well I have a pair of sure headphones
for they work on my laptop they don't
work on iPhones anymore obviously but
they have drivers in them and they're
like suit they're like this clear
coating over silver cord they're like
pretty high-end [ __ ] they sound good but
you know it's for the little ones you
carry in your pocket like air pods
that's like goddamn genius invention way
more easily replaceable for 50 bucks
than a 3,000 yeah easily replaceable and
they just work so well their work which
of these air pods and pies yeah these
little things there's two kinds there's
the content of noise canceling and then
the other kind
most the time why you actually have both
but most the time I use the the regular
one because it sits in my ear better the
noise cancelling I forgot to jam it in
there a little bit but it's great you
could talk to people while you drive and
it doesn't have to go through your ear
the system in your car you know if you
have a you know a Bluetooth setup you
don't speak you don't hear in the
speakers music music you know you said
something to me and I realized like that
that's something that I do and when I do
it I probably have some of my best
results is you were saying a couple
years ago you stopped listening to music
driving to the store absolutely yeah my
car that I have some of my mom some of
my favorite sets after I Drive there's a
car doesn't even have a radio that
little Porsche that I have the red one
because it's so is old and it's like
real loud it's [ __ ] and it's real
mechanical and I'm just I'm so engaged
with it but that I went by the time I
get to the comedy store my brain is
firing right I've been doing something
with it I'm not just pressing autopilot
and just sitting back and relaxing on my
way to the store and riding on this
[ __ ] cloud like the Tesla with that
little Porsche it's like you're right
you hear all the gears you feel it when
you're shifting gears it's like you're
engaged
no music when you get there you but your
brain is fired and you could think about
stuff while you're driving there instead
of like I like listening to sets I
listened to a lot of my sets but I also
like the guy like doing that before
shows listening driving to a show and
listening to a set but I also like
sometimes not listening a [ __ ] just
letting my brain get into a good
creative place just go over the bits go
over what I like about and what I don't
like about just make make myself
concentrate on them with no paper no
nothing just drive it and concentrating
on the bit
today and go through all his emotions
until he drove himself to tears just to
check himself for the day
Wow and I said how can I do that as a
standout I don't need to [ __ ] cry I'm
not in the business to make people cry
so I'll need to cry I just need to be
the best me do you know that I went to
Anthony Robbins right you know I'm a big
Anthony Robbins mm-hmm you know that
right I know you have talked about
Anthony Robbins before that I went I do
believe in a lot of what he's saying yes
I think that a little bit I mean dog
when I went to see him I was a burglar I
ended up a kidnapper something happened
he got through to me and I'm saying he
made me [ __ ] he works to another
level
so I ain't mad at Anthony Robbins you um
saying I got caught I [ __ ] up Anthony
was on the right pace I used to listen
to his cassette I really do believe
stimulus take you there something that
you do to take you to that mind okay he
believes that there's something that we
do you can put yourself in a put
yourself in that space you know and I
really believe there's something to that
yeah for sure okay the reason why
sometimes you're calling me and you're
like joy what are you doing I'm being
honest yeah I'm telling you I'm watching
Pavarotti I'm watching the most most
obscure people who are performers why
wouldn't you tell me that why are you
lying to me because not you go you know
what are you doing in there
I'm right am i right I'm watching BB
King life from writing watch it BB King
live from Africa and I'm watching BB go
into a place that I could only dream
into going but I probably been in my 28
years of doing comedy I've been in there
200 times I want to learn how to get
there more so I believe that on the way
down to the store some mornings I do it
just drive without the car on and think
of a specific time in my life bad a good
break down this situation and see what
happens I'm not breaking open a scab and
I'm not going to see a psychotherapy
I just want to see how I feel about that
situation today hmm you know I always do
I always do that like reflecting right
time alone right
right now I'm thinking a lot about
falling in love with Tommy the [ __ ] I
did Stanhope coming over to my house as
a feature act first and I was an MC at
the broker on Tuesday nights 1991
Stanhope comes as a feature if anybody
ever did that run you knew that the
triple one started Tuesday and Boulder
and Wednesday you had off and then
Thursday you had Craig Colorado I was
divorced but I had a condyle two
bedrooms two-and-a-half bedrooms condo
if the comic was cool on Tuesday night I
didn't bite him to sleep over so you
wouldn't have to pay for a hotel mmm he
only made 35 bucks right they gotta pay
48 for a hotel crazy so if the comic was
cool on Tuesday night say hey man if you
wanna spend the night tomorrow give me a
call tonight you got the hotel here but
if you won't want to drive to Craig to
spend the night first time Stanhope came
he was a [ __ ] feature after the
second time that [ __ ] came he
stayed at my house I walked him to his
car and brought him like food down he
had an apartment he had like a
one-bedroom apartment in this car and
I'll never forget saying what the [ __ ]
is this and he's like I'm homeless we
got a do if you wanna but he was a real
Road Dogg yeah he live got his car a
real Road Dogg yeah so I took his
[ __ ] advice you know that [ __ ] and
jeweler 95 or so I'm getting the car I'm
gonna stick in the back just like him I
had a frisbee in there a basketball I
had everything you could have in there
remember those things that you put in
your radiator the metal and if your
radiator blew fix your radiator I'll see
ya
oh when you broke that [ __ ] yeah I'll
fix a flat
takes a flat oh my god living out of
your car on the road as a character
building it's a what character building
my god every comic that I know that ever
did that there's some of my favorite
people gone through some [ __ ]
you know Road gigs man people that did
road gigs that's a different world man I
remember when I was doing Road gigs
sometimes the booking agent particularly
if I was a middle act they would bring
in a headliner from New York a lot of
times with these guys they were club
guys like gotta forget the guys name but
he was a old club act who worked around
New York City he never really did the
road just did New York City and he and I
did a gig together in Burlington Vermont
and you could see this is like a rare
thing for the guy the guy didn't have a
car because he lived in New York and
didn't know how he was gonna get around
he had to have someone drive him up from
the city wanted to get a ride with me
it's like man I'm not giving anybody a
ride in Vermont that I don't know like
that's just too weird you know this this
gig doesn't pay that much anyway but
that those guys that didn't do the road
when they did man they were like a fish
out of water they'd like New York City
jokes nobody gives a [ __ ] about New York
City when they're in Burlington Vermont
oh they go right through the whole
reliable there were so many comics
though in New York that they would work
the crowd because the crowds were on top
of you the crowds are on top of you in
New York
you know the stages are so small because
real estate was so precious that the
club was stuffed
people would be stuffed into some of
those places like stand-up New York
remember how small that stage was or
Boston comedy you are amp with the ear
yeah
nothing [ __ ] with you know it just gets
itchy oh I remember the [ __ ] New York
Comedy Club was on 74th Street I don't
remember
yeah the 74th on the West Side just a
little close to them yeah that was
stand-up in New York the old one it
needs to be a New York Comedy Club guy
in 91 that's who took me in in 93 I
forget what his name is
is very decent to me that's how I ended
up meeting Mikey Bocchetti who is now
Artie Lange's hey how's already doing is
he doing I checked his you know what I
said he was suffering from anxiety
anxiety yeah I went when I went to New
York I was scheduled to his podcast that
Wednesday and he cancelled he's not
using he's not using no he did a podcast
with me at the Legion of skanks place it
was amazing
he was great it was great to see him
sober and so so alert present so they're
so honest and [ __ ] hilarious he's
like as funny as he's ever been [ __ ]
up nose laughing about it doesn't do
[ __ ] talking about what he did he
snorted glass snorted glass his girl
broke up these pills with a [ __ ] salt
shaker and cracked it and got glass in
snorted glasses nose is bleeding
and he also got knocked out by a guy who
he owed money to guy who he owed money
to hired some kid to collect and the guy
punched him in the nose and smashed his
nose and so he had a double whammy
happened two things at the same time
smoking a snorting glass and then that
brute dude he was so funny he was so
funny and he was so alert it was great
it was like the RDI I knew years ago but
even better like I don't think I've ever
known Artie so you know the circle of
there's a circle it's a spiraling out of
control you get involved it mmm when you
when you're going through it you're not
seeing it yeah once you've done it and
you have the balls and you look back
they're all hilarious I went through it
they're all hilarious but you just keep
getting into trouble
isn't it funny though that that's a
human pattern it's a fun it's a funny
pattern there's so many humans falling
with heroin garage the cops came down
it's things that would never ever happen
under
you know circumstances but the funk of
the drug it just hits you at one time
where remember that everything listen
nobody drives to an open mic with a
Lamborghini you know right you never
seen nobody pull up to an open a
Lamborghini
nobody does cocaine everyone the second
time does they had a bad time doing it
right you do have a really good time at
first or it seems like you having a good
time your body left an opening somewhere
you know just hurry your immune system
did let in Quran of it then sometimes
your soul just has a weakness somewhere
and that's when the coke or the heroin
comes in mm-hmm I know really
but how crazy was I caught up in this
[ __ ] so then he went down this [ __ ]
just hole you know and that's what
rehabs do they catch you they slow you
up they try to identify the problem with
him was this father was it the firing of
you know the radio god no he had the
problems way before that he had problems
when he was on MADtv what set him right
you know that's what the rehab does you
know that's what we what sets you the
[ __ ] off and you gotta get yourself away
from that I found that what set me off
over the years you know there was a time
that could sit here for hours II talk
I'm out on bail and I'm [ __ ] I don't
bail kidnapping come on bail for
second-degree kidnapping second-degree
assault you know I'm I got the worst
roll at me and I'm [ __ ] going in to
see as I read that and clipping tensed
Bruce Springsteen double-set CDs born in
the USA then gone for $80 whatever they
were called for $40 I'm getting 22
apiece I'm taking two a day I'm walking
with the small 220 I got a hundred for
coke 54 we than 50 for lunch that was it
I still remember like doing this for a
month like just like my addiction had me
on this schedule that I wasn't gonna
work well I'm hot I'm bail I'm gonna
show the Sears Roebuck every day and Rob
born by the USA they even had him right
by the door I don't even have to do much
work I just had a walk in walk into
Sears may believe I was looking for a
hammer and then on the way out I just
take her I have four of them pulling my
shirt and walk up one day Joe I'm gonna
pick up like that of them cuz instead of
four I take four it's like the guy says
in our clothes you're gonna move a kilo
you might as well - you're gonna move -
you might as well move five you're gonna
move five you might as well do 10 what's
the difference
so instead of taking four boxes I
started taking like tens
like I would walk out of there Joe Rogan
like a CD [ __ ] thing and one day I
walk out of here we go hey you stop
right there and I'm like what are you
talking to monies they come back with
those CDs they're chasing me and Boulder
mm-hmm in the parking lot of Crossroads
Mall Here I am getting chased one
security guard in the car
and the other guy on foot I could beat
them both up by the way I could beat
them [ __ ] or both of them but I just
can't have no problems so what am i
doing I'm whipping CDs at them as I'm
running and the guys okay stop that
what made me think I was gonna get away
the police is coming and I have a stop
and give him a fake name and [ __ ] you
know hearing him out on [ __ ] bail why
am i robbing [ __ ] seat why we
addicted to it to the thrill I was
addicted to snorting coke and getting my
dick sir do you think there was a little
bit of an addiction to the thrill of
stealing - oh I loved all that cuz you
loved all that doing that [ __ ] later on
with like lighters and [ __ ] oh I love
all that [ __ ] if I'm not in trouble for
something listen I just smoked three
joints for you here
well the Kiley you know you look fine
don't do not know more well it gets you
in a good place but the reefer lets me
know I'm still nothing has changed about
me well I could be an a a right now I'm
be clean and sober I don't do enough to
warrant being [ __ ] on sober mm-hmm
this just lets me know I'm okay
it's like a teddy bear it's like when
people suck their thumb that's all this
is from Miri for now it doesn't really
get me blasted no more yeah I just told
you that let's not give you all these
capsules you won't see daylight till
tomorrow okay oh what's in there a B is
[ __ ] a little bit oxygen THC how many
you takin I can pop two in the afternoon
200 milligrams then take another 200
tonight and I'll be okay once no I got
this new thing called quick Zee quick
Zee quick Z what is that it's a little
towards container if you want to sleep
you come see me
quick Zee quick Zee what's in it
melatonin like triple and they did not
put you to sleep naturally mm-hmm
they've put it in there plus a hundred
milligrams IV the sativa indica or
hybrid marijuana
whoa and you drink it dawg your first
night I drank it I found myself usually
I fall asleep like you do like this
writing reading the computer and you
like this yeah that's a B is this one
I'm away from the computer
right I actually back away and then
slump have you done that one joke yeah
sure I've done that once you have yeah
last week no two weeks ago I got so
[ __ ] doc cuz I thought I was only go
to New York and die from the Corolla
but I actually drank that [ __ ] I ate two
pills oh my god I ate two of these first
nothing happened like I'm like nothing's
happening I drank the [ __ ] liquid and
something started to happen but it
wasn't going fast enough it was like
10:15
I wanted this time when we go to bed so
I pop to morning oh oh my god I all hit
me at once like a Larry Holmes [ __ ]
left hook that night I woke up on the
floor I fell off the chair and the
heater woke me up I have a healer my
office my birth my back was on fire my
fire trench I went into the kitchen I
opened up the refrigerator I pulled out
a half a pound the deluxe boy at Jesus
she had just bought an American cheese I
took a pack of saltine crackers cause in
my mind I might even bread I'm okay I'm
not eating bread I'm ahead of this
[ __ ] the whole thing took off my
mass it was a big chunk of American
cheese in the sleep mask once - oh my
god what the [ __ ] I [ __ ] went out my
wife's idea was for the morning I went
to bed at 4:00 in the [ __ ] like I woke
up at 3:30 and was like what the [ __ ]
happened I must have went down at a
quarter to 11:00 I'd been I probably was
in this position for an hour and I just
fell off the [ __ ] stool and just
laying on the floor nobody saw me that's
how drilled I got that was I think that
was the Wednesday yeah that was the 10 I
don't like to smoke and go to sleep
I don't like to eat it and go to sleep I
just like to go to sleep when I go to
sleep but when I when I get high like if
I get high before bed I have to get out
of bed I gotta grab the computer is
that's what my best ideas come my real
yeah my best ideas come like the first
hour after getting high like the rush
there's like a rush that happens a rush
of wild thoughts that happens for like
the first like 40 minutes to an hour
right after you're high it's like that's
when their pop they're just popping into
your head
they like come on man let's dance like
you got to get up you can't just try to
sleep on that like when those little
moments hit I start getting ideas like
oh okay
this is a time you got to write because
you know how many times you just go
through your day and don't have any
interesting ideas and all sudden you get
high and they come out of nowhere it's
like the most underappreciated engine
for ideas ever it's getting high it's
funny how when I get home at night I
always think of something between the
two stages something always happens
between the main room and the original
or vice versa
and something always happens how I could
do something a little better than what
just happened so when I get home yeah I
do take a piss I wash my hands I that's
the best time to grab my thct going
mm-hmm home ot with the CBN's [ __ ] they
have little breath mints now they're
follow breath [ __ ] you up
trust me oh my god that called sleep the
product is Mikey como and that's um the
tea I drink is called tranquil and it's
every time I got a repeat chamomile mmm
and the Yorba root
oh yeah your muscle your bhumata your
mamata is a stimulant well then it's the
cousin in my sleep whatever is your but
somebody and then you have three
milligrams of THC 10 milligrams of CBN
and like all those other things that put
you to sleep
they got everything no melatonin but Dec
[ __ ] pills it's like a container that
like takes like a little tin like a tin
of little tiny breath mints oh you
better be careful with those two or
three that's it yeah but I also had like
300 milligrams musically the other
things no no no no they I went to Las
Vegas the last road gig I did was Las
Vegas
with those they work don't get me wrong
it's not the same thought the THC that
kills its to CBN Jamie can we find that
with CBN is I don't know I'm appalled
terpenes and right it's one of the dirty
cousins to CBD what is it terpene
officially one of the things things in
it anything that's like what it better
use a great word when you could use the
term confidently and you never you could
say terpene confidently could have
annoyed no that [ __ ] terpenes are what
you smell large diverse class of organic
compounds produced by plants insects
plants so it's just a component of the
plant right good for the same stuff CBD
is so CBN study benefits include pain
relief anti insomnia promotes growth of
bone cells antibacterial
anti-inflammatory anticonvulsant a petit
stimulant very interesting so it sounds
real similar to just THC or CBD so just
another cannabinoid is that what it is
yeah there's some new ones there finding
out - like I've gotten THC a which is
not psychoactive and there's some other
new ones that they're the science is
getting do CBD is [ __ ] great for you
really it's great for you it really I
feel the difference I don't see any
downside I'm not seeing it I'm looking
for it right I'm trying to find out
something this stuff does to you it see
just Google what are the negative
effects of CBD I've never heard of any
of you I have a plate for him now I've
been using CBD cream oh it's amazing
cream yeah my legs yeah what the Vegas
my hat it my skin got dry went somewhere
we start using this done side effects
include nausea fatigue and irritability
no I doubt it I think you're just
talking to [ __ ] yeah blame it on that
CBD man and made me have fatigue
I was irritable because the CBD no you
know what you should have if you take
like more than a thousand milligrams of
CBD at night when you get home you work
out if you legitimately have an injury
like I know it rest the [ __ ] out of me
at night like I like all that [ __ ] I'd
rather take that [ __ ] than hit opioids
like at this point in my life well then
xanax ambien the ambien makes you do
crazy [ __ ] makes you get addicted it
makes you say crazy should do yeah it
makes you say do dumb [ __ ] at night and
make crazy [ __ ] too so mm-hmm you know
what would be the way we want so I go
off the deep end I make a race is common
or some way that I can live with that
ambien doesn't right you don't really
sleep though it just kind of puts you
away for a little bit or you don't go
through a full sleep cycle right who was
telling is that true you don't go
through a full let's see what get this
right ambien doesn't allow you to go
through a full REM sleep cycle really I
don't think so I think it's a different
cycle because when we had Matthew walk
or the sleep expert it was when he was
doing very informative podcast the best
yeah and the one listen let me tell you
something your podcast for Monday the
9th of March of the 8th of March that
was the best podcast of the year which
one that's the one about that one broke
down the coronavirus oh that's this guy
one foster home after all
is the bed that's the one that put the
fear of God into me that's the one that
opened my eyes a little bit more why
people were reacting the way they were
yeah yeah there was a there's a wake up
at all wake up call big wake up call
we got hard to find because I would also
imagine that any negative effects would
be zapped by the pill industry online
the Google it you know somebody says
like I may be at high dosages it might
affect it but the very first thing I
says it says effects of zolpidem which
is ambien had no effects on REM sleep
really so I don't bad second interesting
that's not what Matthew Walker was
saying no I know that I want to said
marijuana doesn't you know you don't go
as deep as you supposed that you think
it's supposed to go there but you don't
go as deep as you why don't we Google
does ambien effect do you get real sleep
on ambien how about that that's I mean
that's I have to dig through like what
would you like me to look I guess
because it's a good question for every
first things that come up are just like
blogs about ambien and like yes I get
sleep this is the very first things I
have to go through 12 pages probably a
result mmm yeah we'd have to figure it
out what you know what I need to talk to
well I know that Matthew Walker was
talking about the negative effects of it
but I need to talk to someone else and
get like get the the rap down or just
listen to what he said about it just get
the rap down because I know there's
something to it where it doesn't totally
it's not the same as just sleeping eight
hours without it you know the same
amount of recovery or something it just
seems like anytime you could take
something it just knocks you out like
that's a chemical just put you out that
can't be good it can't be good for
there's a chemical you take that that
crashes you that's not good
you've done something I mean you're
gonna recover once you crashed but
you've done something very strange
you've taken something that shuts you
off just to me that when I'm up I'm up
am i mop my up oh okay well I'll get up
and then when I'm tired I'll lay down
I'm not taking anything and people like
well I need it for work okay I get it
you need it it just seems to me that if
you want to be healthier taking
something that just makes you go to
sleep is not let me up here yeah it's
one thing if it's a natural alternative
that just relaxes you and a lap but
something that knocks
you the [ __ ] out and when you wake up
you're in a gunfight with the cops
because that's what ambien does you
would Kevin James woke up in the middle
he I talked about it on one of my
specials
he made a [ __ ] turkey went to the
grocery store when I made food and
people came home and they're like what
the [ __ ] coot he's like someone broke
into the house he thought he went to the
supermarket and bought food and made a
meal and he thought that someone broke
into his house and cooked till the
people are in the middle of a drive on
the highway they wake up they have no
idea how they got there they have no
idea some people when they're on ambien
they just ambien walk they do all kinds
of wacky [ __ ] I think people have
committed murders when they're on ambien
I think there was a guy see if that's
true so Matthew Walker says that if
you're not getting the restorative
benefits of sleep from it yeah you're
not getting true sleep
they switch off the top of your cortex
the top of your brain explaining Derk
magazine and put you in a state of
unconsciousness that's not sleep that's
cryogenics Walker the sleeping pill
sleep does not have the same restorative
powers there you go immune boosting to
emotional resilience so of course the
other stuff that you read was shells by
the pill industry trying to fill up the
Google search folks stay up when you're
tired go to bed
my advice to you you know when they
didn't need sleeping pills back in the
[ __ ] pioneer days
take a wagon across the country and
fight off Indians all day you could just
go to sleep man you just sleep you're
tired dad dishes all day you're taught
you're exhausted I've always used Brie
for the sleep I've always used three for
the sleep a and B I've always used
reefer to slow me down a little bit I
know for a fact and always slowed me
down my mind has always been yeah
[ __ ] up like that so something they
should have treated it was something
early on they didn't catch it they
didn't all existed
now I know how to calm myself down
self-medicate you know I know how they
smoke too reefer I brought really dig
the the meditation the last two weeks
so what saw where it took me from where
I was at the word took me from helping
me it do the main thing was which is
accept acceptance is the main thing in
this whole thing that's going on right
now
once you accept it you'll be you'll lose
30 pounds of weight you never lived 20
more years accepting this that you
didn't [ __ ] up and nobody around and you
[ __ ] up you didn't [ __ ] up Joe this is
just didn't [ __ ] up cuz I shot somebody
at the store I acted bad at the store
this is nothing to do with us Frank you
know this is something from life we will
all bounce back from this might be a
year might take two might take six
months you don't know what's gonna
happen I know that it's gonna change
people's lives for the better people
gonna go you know what I didn't want to
work on a [ __ ] office anyway yeah you
know what this is gonna make people
think from outside the box which is
something they needed yeah so there's
both negative and positive from this
whole situation how it works for you is
appeal how it works for you it felt
gonna be a few G well every time there's
a moment of adversity you can you could
recover from that 'vote if you can
recover from that adversity you have an
opportunity it'll grow it's always there
but it was the quote that Raphael Lovato
quoted that inside every seed of
adversity is in and or inside every
adversity is a seed of an equivalent
benefit who was that Think and Grow Rich
was that guy's name again god damn it
this weed in your memory was being 15
Thornhill yes Napoleon Hills book very
interesting book Raphael Lovato jr. he
loves that book that book to him is like
that's like his his one of his
motivational books Joey Diaz let's wrap
this up with 3,000 it's always great to
see I'm glad
Jamie great to see you brother you know
I know Jamie's dying there's no sports
I've been thinking about him a lot
lately what are they doing are they
gonna just put everything aside for a
little more betting on the weather right
now they're like NASCAR is doing like a
virtual League this weekend that they're
starting up with some past drivers and
whatnot yeah oh my god
oh my god you know what I was thinking
of doing like some old of the oh my god
I want some but [ __ ] UFC Unleashed
came through from Kojo II they showed
all three Chuck Randi fights right now
another very interesting well you know
Chuck going in they're not trained and
take a little light get [ __ ] little
em and [ __ ] stopped him and then him
coming back catch them with that [ __ ]
right and then I'm coming back again
that's been great I wish you could
narrate them like the idad was like why
can't he [ __ ] him I should call him we
should talk to him you know when you and
Eddie get together and do them because I
even go eat that's great right now to
get like old fights and put them up it's
not a bad idea no my god this is the
time to do it we should have a fight
companion for old pride fights like yet
some of them I have dad so we should do
like I like I love to go get schooled on
Overeem yeah beginning the Japanese guy
which one the one Sakuraba
Sakuraba I've done O'Gara Brothers oh
they're like that's the education I need
next yeah that's a great idea you see if
I companion with like some of those
great old yeah cards yes yeah we'll pick
out a card pride dynamite or some [ __ ]
there's so many more I put together a
card oh just like top ten fight oh yeah
we could totally do that but it's the
best way I think would be if we put it
together where they could sync it up
like the Dark Side of the Moon and then
watch the whole card with us so we're
gonna press play right now it's starting
here's the first round and three two
well you know like that this is like we
do with a regular fight so they could
they could be synched up so they're
watching it with us yeah you ever see
came through last week it's a great idea
the
that McGregor had everybody on both
fights that they ended up with khabib
Diaz didn't ESPN have something like 11
hours of yes yeah they ended up with
khabib here's the thing about a mcgregor
UFC fights for some strange reason and
I'm not sure why they're as entertaining
to watch the second time as anything of
everything I still have be as McGregor
on my pay-per-view and could be McGregor
dude I've watched Zhang Wei Li and and
you wanting a Jay check I've watched
that five times yes I have I watch it on
my TV at home
I've why it's like watching them cut
gems it's so good and even better that
was so good that was so nerve-racking
that fight was so crazy I've watched
that fight of gang at times I watched
the style bender yellow Romero fight at
least two times I watched John Jones
Thiago Alves I watched at it I mean Iago
Iago Paolo
Paul no no no no Thiago Santos Jesus
Christ cha-cha Alva's welterweight
weed I blame the weed but I watch that a
bunch time wants to Dominic Reyes fight
a bunch of times I watched that fight at
least four or five times watch that
fight with a fine-tooth comb
and I know I still can't call it that
anybody says that this guy wanted that
guy won that fight that's open to
interpretation that third round is open
to interpretation no question
Dominic gray is one the first to no
question John Jones won the last two
it's that third round is that third
rounds like to make it even that seemed
like you know it's hard to say that's
hard to say round I kind of lean towards
maybe Dominic Reyes did enough to win
that round because I think he landed
more volume in that round but John
controlled the center of the Octagon
John put was starting to put pressure on
him John was starting to catch him and
especially towards the end of the round
which I was for whatever reason score
higher the end of the round to me is
like this is when shits starting to
change and then one person might have
got a relief from the bell or the other
person was gaining an advantage that's
what it seemed like at the end of round
3 it seemed like John will start again
and advance watch again
I won't watch it's good it's a good
fight man Dominic Rey is a bad
[ __ ] he put on a show he think
about what he did and how come he stayed
in front of the goat the guy was beating
everybody John Jones has beaten
everybody and Dominic gray has put it to
him got it so close that there's a real
argument that he might have done enough
to win the decision I don't necessarily
agree with that argument I think I
almost kind of agree with a draw if
people saw the draw I could almost see
that third round being a draw but I like
John winning because John was stronger
in the fourth and fifth rounds I think
it means more I think it should mean
more I know it doesn't but it should
it's like the fight was going his way he
was starting to take over that's what
you want to see I mean you want to see
the guy was trying to chase the other
guy down and and beat on him at the end
of the fight who's doing at the end of
the fight well the end the fight was
John Jones but still he impressed and
quite impressive but you got to think
the Thiago Silva not Terro silver Chagos
Santos fight Jesus Christ Joe Silva was
another bad [ __ ] from Brazil but
the Thiago Santos fight was a split
decision people forget that I mean I
don't necessarily agree with it there
was a split decision I thought John won
but it was close enough that one judge
disagreed you know one judge incompetent
or confident you be the judge gave it to
Thiago Santos and you know Thiago Santos
put on a hell of a show it was an
amazing fight but I'd you know John
still the greatest of all time if you
look at all the guys 2d beaten Anthony
Smith OSP lyoto machida Rashad Evans
just go down the line Rampage Jackson
just go down the line Vitor Belfort just
going on the line everybody John beats
everybody Daniel Cormier twice stopped
in the second time Shawn beats everybody
John beats everybody so for Dominic
Reyes to put on a show like that see
this is why this coronavirus is so
[ __ ] up for MMA a that people can
catch and get sick and their loved ones
can catch and get sick of course but be
goddamn there's some good fights that
need to be made and how they're gonna
make them what are they gonna do Tyson
Fury's they're pushing
fury and wilder three they're pushing it
back they have to they don't know what
to do though I think they're gonna try
to push it back to July or something
right to fall that's what it was in July
yeah that's right there's a fight in
Vegas in July I'm supposed to be at the
Park Theatre in July in Vegas you are
the day before the fight yeah that the
one that's next to the MGM I'm at that
place that place where they do the
weigh-ins I don't who knows what I'll be
able to even I don't know I mean max
Holloway said it best it is what it is
let's get the folks right it is what it
is hey we love you people I love you
guys we do thank you for tuning in I
feel like one of the cool things about
this about being able to do podcast this
week with bird and Tom and you it's like
our community's still together you know
we're still together we're still still
having fun together and we we want you
guys to be connected to that that helps
I mean even if it's just it's just a an
E community or it's just a you know a
virtual community it's still all of us
that kind of vibe on these conversations
and have a good time together we're all
in it together including people
listening you know this is a weird thing
that we're doing and we're not gonna
stop because of this virus if we have to
do it from our house if it gets so crazy
they keep me in the house we're gonna do
it well we'll hook it up with some sort
of cameras we'll make it happen and make
it app we're gonna make it happen
idea for you we got you [ __ ] we
got you stay black we love you bye
[Music]